Oh,
it was fucking brutal,
but I was like,
you know,
I've done a bunch of podcasts that dom
sitting there.
He's like,
what are you talking about?
The whole podcast did.
What do you want to talk about?
We talked about sports for about 50
minutes comedy for five and that was it.
It sounds like Dot Moreira and we're
live with Jenny Johnson.
High Five.
What's up?
What up?
First of all,
that's fantastic.
Twitter name.
Thank you.
How'd you get that?
Because Jenny Johnson was taken and I
had to get clever.
I was like,
well I like high five.
Let's go with that.
But I've had people that have told me I
was at you or you're making fun of
people dates be.
I don't think so.
No,
he asked me that.
I had been asked that a lot and I was
like,
what do you mean?
Well Ahi and the number five,
you know the Roman Numerals v.
So like I was going to be Jenny HIV.
What the fuck?
I'm saying do a lot of stupid shit,
but
that's hilarious.
So someone more than one.
I've been asked by several people like
online or in person.
No,
no,
no.
I just like high fives.
Like that was it.
Now that you brought that up is probably
going to be like some blog posts written
about it and a conspiracy will get
formed.
Yeah,
that.
I like that.
That's what you're trying to do.
Right?
That's the type of things that like,
like really wacky people that believe in
the Illuminati would start to sort of
say the d five is actually the jumps in
each.
I'm like,
my birthday's in May to number five,
you know,
it was just like,
okay.
So I was just kind of doing it through
that a little bit too.
Like,
Hey,
high five other number,
you know,
like I actually had no,
it had nothing to do with anything.
The number,
the name Jenny Johnson was just taken.
You sound a little defensive.
I started to believe that maybe I've got
the full blown,
full blown disease.
Is Hiv even the disease anymore?
I mean it is,
but nobody dies.
But now I feel like now it's like
whooping cough or something.
Kids.
Oh my God.
Do you remember the moment when there's
a few moments where I remember like when
Sam Kinison died,
you know,
like things along those lines when you
found out that someone was done.
But when I heard that Magic Johnson had
HIV,
I was in the car with my girlfriend and
we were in Boston.
We were driving.
We were both like,
Holy Shit.
It was like beginning of like the
walking dead when people started to get
sick.
Like,
oh no,
fuck,
it's on.
It is magic.
Johnson of all people Jensen's famous.
I'd say the one that killed me too is a
easy eating.
Yeah.
He died of aids and that was also like,
it's just,
you didn't see that coming.
Like I guess I,
I think I just assumed maybe it was all
in New York.
It was gay guys that are getting,
you know,
like as a,
as a kid,
you know,
I,
that's,
I didn't know any better all in New
York.
That's funny.
Why New York?
I don't know why,
because every,
every scene,
every,
you know,
like everything you saw in the news that
it was always coming from New York
because they were too lazy to get out in
the rest of the world.
That's what you would see.
I'm like,
well,
how does this happen?
Yeah,
it's a weird one.
That was a weird one.
Like easy.
He was the weirdest one because like,
what was he doing?
Was He doing intervenous drugs?
Was He having unprotected sex?
Sex?
No,
it was just.
But it was with a lot of
girls that had,
that had used it as Tommy Lee not have
aids.
Then how does it like,
there's a lot of of titus or something,
but doesn't he have that from heroin?
Allegedly.
They're all doing it in the bud.
Whoa.
How dare you
didn't mean it.
Isn't that the Charlie Sheen thing?
Charlie Sheen was blowing some guy that
was smoking crack and there's a video it
was allegedly
did,
but I didn't know if it was real.
Like when Charlie,
she even goes on.
Matt Lauer it all and it wasn't like
Magic Johnson spelled where it was like,
and I'm going to be an activist for
this.
He's like,
it's over.
Not panties whores.
Any anymore money there.
There was nothing that was good or
productive.
Know with people that I'm an activist.
No,
just not paying these horses anymore.
I've paid $10,000,000 and I'm done
because he's paid $10,000,000.
Blackmailed by a bunch of different
women who had gotten to his house and I
guess open his medicine cabinet and saw
his HIV medication.
Took a picture with their cell phone and
said,
pay up or I'm sending this out to the
press if I was Charlie Sheen,
so I took that shit to get high.
If you smoke crack and take HIV
medication,
you go to another dimension.
So good walking.
Amazing
for a little riddle in there to cut off.
I've got to imagine that stuff has got
to be somewhat psychoactive.
I don't know.
I have this drink and do drugs with like
other sure.
Street drugs with it.
Yeah,
because like if you do certain drugs
with other drugs that dances them,
right?
Candy flipping and all that jazz.
What is Candy Flip Candy flip is this
wacky kids when they do the acid with
molly,
like they do Mtma and acid together.
Wow.
It's supposed to be amazing.
Supposed to survive.
If I didn't have kids,
I'd fucking jump in there.
I will give it a shot.
I feel like this might be worth dying
for.
I can't leave behind him.
How'd your dad died serving his country.
It was flipping.
My Dad was candy.
Flip it with some 20 year olds.
Get to say that I guess.
Right?
I'm sure they brag about it.
Yeah,
that's,
that's my old man.
That poor fuck.
He's a fascinating guy though because he
is fascinating.
He was on one of the worst sitcoms ever
that was successful.
Like that fucking two and a half men was
so bad.
It's.
I tried to watch one episode.
I couldn't.
I couldn't do it.
I mean,
I couldn't even make it through like so
the next break for,
you know,
it's not for me,
but it's for somebody obviously giantly
successful and to even have him fired
and to bring another lead on and it
still works,
but it didn't get canceled it.
I know,
but I thought it worked for a while.
How long do they do it with a coach?
A couple of years.
It did work for a bit.
Even noticed the people that are
watching that,
they're all on Ahcccs.
They're just fucking sitting in front of
the TV,
whacked out of their head.
They're
just waiting for the laugh track to kick
in so they can laugh it.
The commercial going to be on.
They get excited for commercials.
So commercial coming on soon and I'm
sure the commercials were really
appropriate for that shout down.
Well those guys,
that guy who Charlie Sheen feuded with
him.
Yeah,
he's awesome at making those kinds of
sitcoms.
He knows that he's done it a bunch
successful as shit to that guy.
If I was on a sitcom with him,
I would ask no questions.
He knows exactly what the fuck he's
doing.
You had read the script and go,
this is.
This is the funniest thing she'd ever
read.
Ready to go.
Just tell me what the words are right
before I say
this,
what are rehearsed this?
But it's perfect.
No,
it's amazing.
It's totally amazing.
He knows how to hit that frequency.
There's like a,
like a dog whistle.
Is it just,
is it people in Oxy,
do you think?
Or do you just think it's like kind of
middle America just get home from work
and it's,
it's,
um,
it's on CBS.
There's definitely that.
There's definitely the Middle America
thing.
It's not offensive and it's a,
it's an easy watch,
you know,
like I've always said like,
how the fuck does anybody watch keeping
up with the Kardashians until I watched
it and the fucking thing is so bad,
but it's compelling the air out loud and
just shit talk,
like allow things.
I punched my dog.
No,
don't do that.
I feel like a lot of people,
I feel like a lot of people hate watch
it.
Yeah,
they definitely for sure.
I think there's plenty of people,
sadly enough that like it.
There's a lot of people that like,
I think a lot of people actually watch
it just because they hate it.
Well,
it's,
it's one of those things is they've
become,
there's so much focus on them that
they've become a thing.
So when,
when the camera's on people.
I have this theory about television fame
and just any,
any form of media and my theory is that
it hijacks these ancient reward systems
that are in place for us to follow
successful people.
So like say if we were going to tribe
together and all the three of us were in
a tribe together and Jamie just fucking
slayed all the intruders and figured out
how to get the food and new world,
the water was,
we'd be like,
we've got a foul Jamie.
Jamie's a bad motherfucker.
We got to follow him.
And so Jamie would talk in front of the
Campfire and we would listen.
That's sort of like a natural thing.
You follow successful behavior.
Well,
when a camera's on someone for whatever
reason,
we,
we think that that person is successful.
So they talk,
they talk and we see all the money they
have,
we see the cars they drive and all the
nails and the purses and all the jazz
and we'd go,
oh,
they have all the good stuff.
We have to follow them.
And it sort hijacks this thing that's
weird.
I don't think we're designed for media.
I think that television and film and
music and all that stuff,
it hijacks this part of,
of,
of being a human being that is a.
it's just unaccustomed to these sounds
and these images,
like you go to a movie and you see a,
you know Brad Pitt or whatever.
His head is fucking 15 feet tall.
Every time he talks the music plays is
the words are perfect because they're
all labored by a group of writers.
They've worked at it for weeks to get
the right sequence of words and the
right order and the right way to say it.
And they practiced it hijacks you and
then you run into them in person.
You're like,
oh shit,
you are
dumb as shit.
Holy Hell.
There was an interview that he did once.
I forget who the fuck it was,
um,
who he was doing an interview with
those,
like,
who's this fucking moron that,
uh,
whoever the guy is like Larry King's
interviewing,
like,
who the fuck is this?
It was on TV and then I turned around
the corner and I saw that it was Brad
Pitt.
I was like,
Holy Shit.
Brad Pitt.
Dude.
Was it bad?
You're boring as fuck.
Yeah.
It was boring.
It is.
Is it worse that they're boring or is it
worse when they have been famous for so
long that they have the answers to
everything?
I think he's probably so tired from
fucking Angelina Jolie all the time that
he just has no energy for thinking.
And all those kids was kids running
around screaming and before her it was
Jennifer Aniston.
Probably reading scripts are there all
the time till 3:00 in the morning just
in brush brushing each other's hair and.
But he doesn't have to be,
you know,
it's almost like he's like a lottery
winner.
He's got great features.
He was a movie star from the time he was
very young.
No need to develop a personality
whatsoever.
If you're pretty,
it works for you.
I've looked at it again,
you know,
here's my thing on Angelina Jolie and
Brad Pitt who out of all the,
like the really famous movie star type
people has ever done more good.
Like that is true.
They do so much good.
There's so charitable.
They're always involved in all these,
uh,
charitable
functions and go to the shitty parts of
the world to adopt like 50 kids a week.
Constantly adopting kids.
This gang of kids have a gang of kids.
That's entirely true.
I don't think you have all those kids at
attention.
They don't.
They have a tribe.
I bet they each have a nanny.
The nanny think they each have a spotter
and
each kid has their own.
Whether the dudes boring or not,
but I don't know,
maybe those fucking interviews are
boring to,
you know,
it's like,
it's far.
Jesus wasn't the.
I don't even know if it was Larry King.
I,
I can't remember who the hell it was he
was talking to.
But I was,
I remember I was in the other room and I
was like,
who is this boring dude?
It's getting interviewed.
And then I turned the corner.
I was like,
that's Brad Pitt proud.
You're boring,
boring.
You should be fucking psyched.
He should be like a brat pack.
I think it's really funny when you go to
like,
um,
if I have like people come into town,
they always want to go to a taping of a
show,
you know?
And so I've used whatever connection I
have.
Okay,
we'll go to this.
I love watching the painful look on the
interviewer's face during commercials,
you know,
like whatever show it is like fuck that
fucking guy,
you know,
where they're just reaching and it's
really hard.
Like I can tell,
you know.
Then there's those guests.
It just get it.
They're very likable and they're good at
it and a chatty and work the crowd and
everything.
Like I saw,
I think it was like Nick Cannon was on
Ellen I have,
I don't give two shits about.
But the guy did it right.
Like he was good with that audience.
Right.
You know,
he said the little funny jokes and he
was real and then I saw some other guy
go on and he's like,
well,
this is one of my first interviews I've
given on empire.
I was like,
I don't watch empire,
and
the sad clown in the audience.
He had prepped whatever it was he was
going to say,
but everything he wanted to say was so
fucking lame.
You just had to watch.
Her face was just like [inaudible]
just struggling,
going through the whole thing.
It was like,
God,
that's the worst part about those shows
and the best part about doing a podcast.
Like I only have people on that I want
to have on.
So it's all up to me.
I decide like,
hey,
maybe Jenny Johnson,
hi,
five.
Be Awesome to have on a podcast.
Boom.
And then those people,
they have to get like,
people that are on radio shows or radio
shows.
Don't ever interview radio show people.
I think I made that up other than Howard
Stern.
What radio guy ever gets interviewed?
Uh,
no,
I was going to say like rush,
but they have to.
They have to interview people.
They don't really give a fuck about.
It's like CNN or whoever it is that they
work for.
Sets it up.
One of my favorite ones was when Chelsea
handler was on with a fuckhead.
What's his name?
The English dude.
That doesn't work there anymore.
Oh yeah.
Oh God.
Ugh.
Fucking tool.
He's so gross,
but I don't know.
Maybe he's a nice guy.
Maybe we stop saying that he's gross on
on a show.
I'm not a fan of the shitty says to you.
I'm like,
yeah,
yeah.
Well we go back from a tabloid
environment living work for like the sun
or one of those companies that got
caught,
but tapping into voicemails of people
that had died and the family got upset
because they thought that the person was
still alive because they were checking
their voicemail was actually the
whatever tabloid.
Yeah.
Whatever shit person sold their soul to
the devil and Chelsea handler did it and
Chelsea handler gives zero fucks.
She doesn't have any fucks left,
does not care.
She doesn't know.
Fox does not care and she tortured him.
She tortured him because she was like,
no wonder why your show's getting
canceled,
like you're fucking terrible at this.
And she like,
she was calling them out like that in
between takes.
He didn't talk to her.
He would just start checking his phone,
looking at twitter and really seeing
what people thought about them there.
Oh,
it's.
She brutalized him and she's one of
many.
She's one of our,
he just goes into these debates on
armed,
like he went into this debate with Ben
Shapiro,
who's this right wing Guy,
a very smart guy,
and like if you're going to debate this
guy,
you got to have your fucking facts in
order.
And he just didn't.
He went into the gun debate with him and
he just destroyed and he called him out
on his outrage peddling that he was
immediately going to like,
you know,
in the debate that he was going to
immediately bring up sandy hook and
bring up all these different people and
that the children that died and that he
was going to immediately use that as
like this cry for outrage.
And he called him on it before he could
ever do it.
And you could see piers Morgan was like,
he's taken all his weapons away.
Hit the end of eight mile.
It's brutal if you ever seen it.
I've never seen him do it.
Oh,
who appears?
Piers Morgan and Ben Shapiro fencing.
That one's pretty good.
Yeah,
totally.
Okay,
let's watch it.
Pull up a pierce.
Morgan gets destroyed by Ben Shapiro.
I kind of love that though.
I like when people are just.
I can't stand all that stupid so.
Well those shows that whole type of
show.
It's so.
It's,
it's,
it only exists because you have a
network,
right?
So you have a network which is this
gigantic thing that has had programs on
forever and they have all these
advertisers that they do business with
and they have these commercials.
They're gonna sell.
So essentially the show is only,
it's only an advertiser for advertisers.
That's what it is.
Like all these interviews and all the
different programs they have,
all they're doing is trying to get you
to lock in long enough so they could
slip an add in.
So every 15 minutes I'll slip ads in and
that's what they sell.
What they really sell is ads.
So didn't give a fuck what you want.
It's not personality driven,
it's not.
It's not about establishing something
that's interesting and fascinating.
And Hey,
we're doing good work here.
No,
it's just about selling ads like that.
I was a news producer for like almost 12
years where you really were a and
Austin,
San Antonio and Houston.
Oh Wow.
Texas knows top producing first and then
I just wanted to make more money so I
got the news,
but it was still like,
you know,
you have to know all that crap.
You have to get your stories.
And here was a watch.
This is pierce Morgan gets owned by but
in a video.
So I found like a five minute version.
So
in American
TV series
American.
So why am I of only on this issue?
Because what you do,
and I've seen it,
I've seen it repeatedly.
What you tend to do is you tend to
demonize people who differ from you
politically standing on the grades that
the children will see it.
Not saying they don't seem to care
enough about the decades.
If they cared more about the decades,
they would agree with you on policy.
I think we can have a rational political
conversation about balancing rights and
risks and rewards of all of these
different policies,
but I don't think that what we need to
do is humanize people on the other side
is as being unfeeling about that,
about what happened in January.
You accused me of standing up the
grades.
I've seen you do it.
Liquors,
like I say,
update.
Let me.
You can keep saying that,
but you've done it repeatedly.
Well what you do and you keep sending
those folks if they disagree with you
politically,
then somehow this is a violation of what
happened in Sandy Hook and you get I,
I really like to hear your policy
prescriptions for what we should do
about guns because you respect the
second amendment and you know I brought
this here for you so that you can read
it.
Constitution.
I really like for you to explain to me
what you would do about guns that would
have prevented what happened in Sandy
Hook.
If you want to do what you did in the
UK,
right,
which is banned,
virtually all gone.
That is at least a fair argument and we
can have a discussion about whether
that's something that we ought to do
very clear what I want to do,
which is exactly what Kelly wants to do
it.
Rather than talk about that rather than
address your comments to me about the
staffing of the grades of children
starting to trust them too long because
he agrees with everything I've been
saying because he thinks the same way.
What does that do to talk to someone
else?
I think it was Gabby giffords.
Was it?
Yeah.
So he's just now picking a different
shooting
total.
Now we got him.
He agrees.
What was it like doing news work is fun.
If it bleeds,
it leads.
Is that true?
Like what are the conversations that
nightcrawler show with nightcrawler
movie?
Is that what somebody get burned back at
babies?
We'd have a lead tonight
per and a bag of
whatever's new.
Whatever's you know,
when Houston,
you know,
sometimes it'd be an apartment fire
southwest Houston,
like it's just whatever's happening.
You know,
it's,
it's local news and so,
and in Austin I did more sports which
was more fun and then when I made the
transition to news I was in San Antonio
and in Houston and it's as a producer,
you know,
you write the newscast,
you're writing with the anchor site,
they're talking heads and then you go in
the booth,
you all right,
three,
two and you know,
it was fun for awhile and then I think
it actually got under my skin a little
bit.
I was always doing like comedy and stand
up and everything on the side.
And then when I realized I could do that
full time instead of news I got out
while you were doing the news,
you were still doing stand up around
town.
Was this during the last stop days?
A.
Well,
Houston and in Austin it was like 2000
to 2004,
maybe city.
I opened at cap city one time,
but I did like the ones on sixth street,
like Velveeta room was just learning.
I was just starting out so you know,
it wasn't that great.
I wasn't gonna be a headliner at cap
city at that point.
What is it like working with
newscasters?
Because they are the most bizarre
television personality.
Like there's really nobody that is more
arrogant
than your local newscaster,
you know,
it's not because it's that person that's
been there forever and everyone around
town knows him,
but the moment they cross out of town,
nobody knows who they are.
So they just,
they're very big,
big egos and sometimes they'll try to,
you know,
flex nuts and god isn't ready.
I just sit down old man,
you know,
just put the thing on.
Like I would never take shit from them,
but a lot of people would get their
feelings hurt sometimes.
Bizarre folks,
because they're in the entertainment.
They are,
they're essentially.
Yeah.
What their entertainment is like.
They have a voice that's soothing for
the news,
right?
There's a way of delivering the news.
It's like the way someone would sing a
song where like it,
the melodies sort of like interacts with
your ears and a very pleasant way.
And just to go from story to story,
you know,
and you just try to make it more
interesting.
So the directors like let's do a two
shot,
right?
It's going to one favorite is when they
do banter in between to fucking stupid.
They really are from weather to from
anchored a whether from news to sports
and it's like.
So it's just like we were saying about
that game yesterday.
I write down exactly like we would just
be in this town.
Purpose says the worst thing ever.
Well certainly interesting in local
news.
Hey,
taking the kids to ballpark this week
and we'll go ahead and let you know what
we're looking at.
Right,
right,
right there.
Brought me to like
make it stop.
Did you ever see that one where the girl
she was talking about,
she was trying to talk about music and
she used the term Jigaboo.
She was like Jigaboo music.
Don't think I've seen them all to.
She didn't know.
Was she a reporter?
Yes.
She was a reporter and she was talking
about something.
She goes,
Oh,
you know,
it's like that Jacob Music.
It's like Jigaboo music.
And the person she was talking to was a
fucking black guy and he was like,
oh,
it was a black guy,
right?
Wasn't it?
Maybe a baby girl,
baby girl?
No,
no,
no.
First of all,
you look deep in her eyes.
You see the back of her skull and look
at the dude.
Want to take a moment to address a
comment that I made yesterday?
Oh,
this is her apology.
Apology.
We'll just take a moment.
Have you ever noticed like your local
wonderful
look at his face?
Look at his face.
And he's like,
I mean,
your family knows,
right Jacob?
Uh,
yeah.
That's fine.
What's called,
which is for.
He's like,
she's got a beautiful voice.
Yes,
yes.
Fucking going.
You in trouble.
I'm going to smile through this and keep
my.
Wait.
So that commercial break,
when I explained to you
what you've just done to our viewers
gighub you jigaboo or we would have I
think one of the funnier things,
it shouldn't be funny,
but it was funny is so our reporters out
there live shots so whatever's going on
and they were in a live truck so they
have to feed the video and we'll cut the
video and say what's the end out cue of
that voicemail or yeah,
I mean the votes out or whatever.
So if there was something that was like,
there was a drive by shooting now that's
not funny,
but witnesses to things like that.
When the camera gets on them,
there was a lady holding her baby that
at coke and the bottle,
she weren't a boys to men tee shirt and
she was like well you know this here
darious and he,
he's so cute and he,
we want him to do modeling.
Did you say coke?
Like Coca Cola.
Coca Cola,
baby.
Yeah.
You know like that kind of classic.
When she gave the baby Coca Cola,
the baby was drinking like a soft drink
out of a bottle at the fucking shit.
No,
I'm not.
This is like,
you know,
the projects.
It's like,
do you know how much sugar is in a
fucking coke?
Like think about the size of a baby's
body.
Well,
the baby just had bullets whizzing by,
it said to,
through the drive by.
So maybe.
Yeah.
I mean it was just.
And then the mom just promoting the
baby.
Not talking about the people that were
just gunned down,
just like trying to get him a modeling
job because she thought dairies,
we keep,
you know,
and he should be on it.
We're going,
oh yeah,
no that's not gonna.
Make it cut that show.
There was a guy,
a lot of guys like to try out there
rapping skills while you interview them
for like crimes.
Like did you see the drive by,
there was this,
this store was broken into and the,
you know,
the clerk was shot,
oh,
here's what this witness here.
What's your name,
sir?
Then because the camera guy,
let's say,
say your name,
spell it so that we can cut it.
We,
I mean these don't even make the error,
but it would just be like so,
so,
uh,
okay.
Now tell us what you saw.
Well,
one,
two,
three,
I saw them
wrapping.
You're like,
this is your big break.
This is what you chose to like,
this is never going to make the air
dude.
But I guess they think maybe will they
don't know.
They don't know.
There's layers and layers in our society
of people that are in the worst possible
scenario and the best possible scenario.
That's one of the worst scenarios we
have available in the United States of
America as the ghetto.
A yeah,
you would see it and it was just so
like,
oh my God,
I cannot believe y'all shot this.
And half the time I'm like,
I know the camera was fucking with me.
You know,
like sending that in.
Like,
I think you're gonna like this,
you know,
the sound byte.
We just got to get jaded at all.
Seeing like really fucked up shit over.
And I did.
And that started to bother me,
that it didn't,
like I could just see it,
write it,
put it in,
and I could remove myself from that
situation,
but then there would just be those times
like something really bad
happened and it's like it was personal
or it was like we actually had our sky
helicopter crashed and the two people
were killed like our coworkers.
And so that was something that was like,
it was Kinda the first,
like the beginning of the end for me
where I couldn't stop,
you know,
I couldn't do it.
I used to do like,
everything felt very personal.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
So that was kind of a,
that sucked.
But I was,
you know,
I'm glad I did it for as long as I did
and I did well.
But do you talk about it on stage at
all?
Um,
sometimes.
But
I guess sometimes it just depends on the
context or whatever's going on.
But sometimes we'll talk about it.
It seems like it'd be right or maybe
write something about it because it
seems like it would be so ripe for
material and just what it's like.
That movie.
It is night stocker,
right?
Xeloda is nightcrawler.
Nightcrawler.
I haven't even seen that one yet,
but I heard it's great.
It's really creepy.
Jake Gyllenhaal will.
Will.
He looks wrong.
Shirt and shit.
He's all scrawny and creepy looking now.
He's so good.
He's such a good creeper.
Like it's perfect.
It's like maybe it's too good.
Well I just think he's got it off.
He can become.
Not that guy in the but he can become
people.
Yeah.
Know.
And he just did such a good job of
capturing the sort of sociopathic
personality of someone who would
ambulance chaser and I.
Well I think that happens a lot.
I mean people that want to get the
story,
break the story first and you know,
to try to break a story first,
especially if it's something horrible
you,
you do feel like when you're done it's
like,
you know,
just trying to call people and trying to
dig up shit and you're just wasn't for
me.
After awhile I could imagine I have a
friend who's a cop and he's told me that
they'll get to a scene and someone who
had been shot and people,
you know.
No,
no one even bats an eye.
They'll,
they'll start eating donuts,
like literally eating donuts like right
next to the body,
like no one to care for them.
It's work.
It's just a crime scene and start
cracking jokes.
Sure.
Yeah.
And,
and that,
you know,
I don't want to say like I went there
but I mean sometimes I,
you know,
like we would see a video,
the full video before it's been edited.
Then we would edit out the dead per.
And it is weird when you're just doing
that and thinking absolutely nothing of
it.
Just cut that.
Is there any pressure to show like more
like the,
there's like libel laws that you have to
follow in news like in,
you have to know those going into it,
that what you can and can't say what you
can and can't show,
you know,
you can't say like you were saying like
allegedly or you know,
there's certain things like that.
You can't say it's a fact when it's just
what it has to come from a legit news
source.
So the Associated Press or CNN,
you know,
like you,
you have to be able to cite the source
that you got the information from.
You can't just say,
my aunt called and said,
you know,
this just happened and that's not a
credible.
One of my favorite ones was this a news
report on an arson.
These people,
their house got lit on fire and this
girl is interviewed and she's like,
I don't want to name no names,
but uh,
it was my cousin because he's been
trying to get with means.
And I think he's the one that lit the
house on the what are,
had been trying to have sex with me.
Have you seen that Jamie?
Yeah,
pull that one up.
See if.
Well,
because we broke up and he's mad about
it because it's so hilarious.
This lady is.
It's just like.
Yeah,
that's why she's like,
I don't want to name no names.
Here we go.
Dan and amy.
I am Elizabeth Berg and I'm just going
to step out of the way now so you can
take a look at this scene.
What is happening right here behind me?
You can see that firefighters are still
working to make sure that this fire is
out.
Smoke is still in the hearing and
firefighters are still over here trying
to make sure that everything gets under
control.
Barrage here.
That is when a fire is.
Heather,
don't me.
You woke up around 3:45 and you saw
this.
What happened?
I woke up and said beating on the doors.
My neighbors.
I opened up the door.
My neighbors were like,
get out,
get out.
You know,
so well opened up the door.
I see.
Just blazing from the garage and I woke
him up,
my husband
out as fast.
Move the vehicles out of the way and I
had him go back in the house to get our
two dogs that we had in there.
When you got outside and you saw what
was happening,
you saw what was going on,
what were your thoughts face in the
background?
My Gosh.
Oh my gosh.
You know,
I didn't ever think it was going to
happen to us.
Do you know how this buyer story up?
Yes,
I do.
It was cousin my cousin and I don't want
to mention no names.
And you said you think your cousin
started this?
Do you know how or why?
He's mad because he couldn't.
He can't get with me.
I'm married to my husband and
my second cousin.
Marie short?
Yeah,
he put it.
He already put him in the hospital once
last month.
I figured he's going to do something
else.
Should be on cost.
Not on the news for the look at the guy.
How is he not dying?
Laughing?
Well,
he's not very good at his job either.
It's kind of clunky.
It's a tough gig.
It is a tough Gig,
but that's not a normal reaction to
someone saying that he normally acts was
a what?
Your cousin hold up.
I mean he's got to stand there with his
tie and professionally and not smile or
laugh or go.
What the fuck?
Oh,
aware.
First of all.
Where's that fucking town?
Where does deliverance burger.
But it's always those Weirdo towns.
I have a friend,
she works out here for the local Fox
station.
Lawrence.
Ivana is her name and she had,
I love it because she's made the soup
tmz for all of her call called John
Boehner.
John Boehner.
And I was like,
everything.
And she's like,
Boehner.
It does look like Boehner.
Like if I saw that in a teleprompter,
I would have to.
Don't say.
Did you see or what happened with him?
He got busted because he,
he's renting an apartment that is owned
by the indoor tanning lobby.
Stop it.
No,
no,
no.
It isn't orange phase.
I retweet it.
That I retweet it today.
Uh,
it's called Gen briny.
Briny.
How do you say her name?
She tweeted it at me.
Please tell me I retweeted it because
it's so ridiculous.
It's not a new story from 2013,
but yeah.
Really?
Yeah.
Well,
everybody's always wondered why this
guy's Tan all the time and he's always
said,
no,
no.
Yeah,
I mean he looks bright orange and you're
watching the state of the union like
tanning bed lobbyist,
indoor tanning.
Look at it as fancy as fuck.
I'm orange.
As long denied.
That is perpetual skin colors.
Result of some of those tailoring.
He just spends a lot of time outdoors.
The Ohio Republican is known to say,
but despite his repeated denials,
using tanning beds,
Boehner has ties to the industry.
You just said Bonar.
It's Bonar b o e h n e R.
It's Bonar.
You do you get baner out of that?
That's not been.
No,
that's not painters.
Bar that's boner.
Not only has he accepted campaign
contributions from a group called the
indoor tanning association,
but when actually lives in a DC
apartment owned by a lobbyist for the
American suntanning association.
First of all,
how gross is politics?
This fucking guy can live in apartment
owned by a lobbyist
for someone who contributes to tanning
association of a.
that's a real.
The American suntanning association.
That's a real group.
I did not know that.
That was.
How can that even be a group
and how was the only paint?
1,600 bucks a month for rent in DC.
DC's fucking expensive.
That guys
crooked crooked to.
There's something else going
on everywhere.
So politicians.
I hate all politics.
I'm a political atheist.
Are you one of them?
Good for you.
Let me to end up lying.
I mean,
you're banking on somebody.
Wait a minute.
Bernie Sanders.
You think he's lying?
Bernie,
I think Brittany needs to run for like a
homeowners association
in Boca Raton or something like that.
Bernie,
a nice cold.
The sac,
the sac ping pong championships on the
one percent of the CULDESAC.
Bernie Sanders is an interesting guy
though.
He's at least getting young people
excited because they're hoping and
praying that someone is different and no
one is different but him.
He's the one guy that's coming along,
let's saying trump's different in,
in a way,
in a bad way,
but he is.
I actually will say I was backed into a
corner and somebody was like,
well,
say something nice.
I'm glad he's not lying.
I
believe he believes every single thing
that he's saying.
I don't think he has a team of campaign
managers telling them what to say.
I'm pretty sure that he just gets up
there and just start spewing crazy.
But he believes that lets it rip.
It's worth a few billion.
He's like,
fuck it,
let's roll the shit.
Yeah,
I mean,
I,
there's something that's kind of
hilarious about that part,
but other than that,
they're all full of shit.
There's a recent bill or a vote that's
going to take place in the UK to try to
ban him from entering the UK for hate
speech.
This is like a serious consideration and
it's going on right now.
He's um,
for uh,
the stuff that he said about Muslims,
he just said,
I mean,
at some point you're like,
I think that everybody was kind of on
board at first.
Like all the old crazies,
somebody saying what we're all thinking
that it's kind of people and then he
just hasn't stopped talking and I think
now they're like,
whoa,
yeah,
come on buddy,
you crossed we get your back.
But now kind of spewing some crazy.
Like I,
I actually think that like all these old
people that like him believe that Muslim
is a terrorist organization group.
Like I don't think that they get that.
That's,
that's like they think Al Jazeera,
that's actually a TV channel.
It's not a like the Taliban that Brown
Peoples Jihad,
Jihad,
Jihad and whatever.
Yeah,
well people are terrified of people from
other cultures,
but when you've got all their cultures
that are involved and things like,
you know when Isis.
But when people have to understand is
people,
isis is killing more Muslims in there.
Are Anybody,
most of the people that they're killing
or Muslims?
Yeah.
Like they know they're just bad.
There's this battle that they're,
they're like they're criminals.
I mean,
it's,
I don't know why this annoys me,
but when I'm watching the news or
reading the news,
which I prefer to read it because it
annoys me,
not watch it,
but people will say,
well,
we know we're waiting to find out if
this was a terrorist attack,
like the San Bernandino thing before
they release those names.
Once they released their names,
therefore it became a terrorist attack.
Don't you think that like the Sandy Hook
Guy,
that was kind of.
He was terrorizing people,
but I like that they have to be a brown
in order to be a terrorist.
Well,
that's our new.
Isn't that weird though?
Our new enemies,
the war on terror and terror has to be
like.
It's like the Germans.
We have to go up to the Germans and the
Japanese or the terrorists,
the terrorists.
It's country.
But what does tear me,
and it doesn't mean brown people do it
bad.
We renamed the country,
you know Japan,
they call themselves the poem.
I don't know if you know what we're
going to wait because I remember Pearl
Harbor.
There's all these people that believe
there are in other countries,
but as Americans we get to dictate what
their actual alarms are,
so we're just going to decide to call it
all terror.
So these are terrorists.
They live in terror.
That's the part of the world called
care.
You're not allowed to come over here.
We'll put you in camps like we did the
japs.
That's some dark shit,
man.
So horrible.
I was talking to my mom who lives in
Houston,
conservative Republican and all those
fun things.
So I love poking her at the stick.
It's really funny.
And when she said,
oh,
it was terrorists in San Bernardino,
and I was like,
well,
I mean anybody that did that is a
terrorist.
Doesn't matter.
When we find out what their name was,
Jenny,
the terrorists are like the really bad
ones
was like,
I begged him.
I don't know.
I think the Sandy Hook,
I was pretty bad.
I got to say,
I don't think he was awesome.
The fucking Colorado movie theater guy.
That's a terrorist.
No white guy with the orange hair of the
real bad ones though.
He's.
He can print announces.
Yeah,
if you can pronounce his name,
just not as bad as the guys that saw he
lumped.
That'd be that bad,
bad stuff.
Bad News.
Well,
it,
it bugs me when people won't criticize
Islamic terrorists or Islamic people
though,
because they are worried about being
Islamophobic.
Like Islamophobia is a weird one.
That's a weird one though.
Anything that's a phobic like,
well,
it's the um,
what's the word I'm looking for you?
Like if you're on a watch list or
whatever,
you know,
you're,
I'm drawing a big fucking blank.
What is it called me?
Like,
prejudging somebody here.
I'll just.
Yeah,
there was some prescreening.
whatever.
You're making an assumption here.
I've stereotype,
you know,
like whatever.
And
that's okay.
Sometimes
I don't think it's a bad,
like I heard this couple one time I was
on a flight and this family and they're
completely dressed Muslim,
you know,
the face covered in magazines,
old people just like,
you know,
the Gilligan's island,
old people,
you know,
just,
and they're like hitting each other like
this guy.
I'm like,
no,
I don't care about those people.
I care about the guys that are going to
come on board with slacks that they've
just bought at Mervyn's or something and
will button down.
It's still get creases like no luggage,
you know,
um,
if that's who's going to freak me out on
a plane as the ones that just are trying
to fit in fuse,
coming out of their shoe,
not the ones that are like fully
standing out with all of it.
Like,
no,
sorry.
I know I,
I,
I will prejudge.
Yeah.
Because I'm not going to just go,
well,
I don't want to offend anybody so let me
get on this plane at these fucking
creepy people.
Cool.
But what I was getting at is it,
it's just weird that people will call
you out on being Islamophobic,
but at the same people will openly mock
Christians.
Sure.
Like,
they'll,
they can openly mock scientologists they
should.
But,
but if you,
for whatever reason,
I guess,
well I guess the,
the legit angle would be obviously
because we're at war.
We were at war with two different
countries and we're still in
Afghanistan,
right?
A lot of troops still in Iraq and more
now than before.
Right.
And we just send some new ones over
there,
but.
And those people that are involved in
the conflict over there are Islamic or
are Brown.
Right.
So I guess it,
it lends the idea
that like,
well you shouldn't be Islamophobic,
you shouldn't be critical or prejudice
against Islamic people,
but it's just,
it's an ideology like lucky first of
all,
excuse me,
any,
any religion is stupid,
but they're all dumb.
I was just watching bill burrs stand up
and I was laughing so damn hard about
and talking about scientology and he
goes,
yeah,
it's funny.
I mean you're,
God's name is Ron,
you know,
get a driver's license and a social
security card.
He's like,
but I found out about it when I was an
adult.
When you're a kid,
you don't question it,
you know,
grew up Catholic,
right?
He's like,
yeah,
you,
why would you?
Sure.
Yeah.
Three days later came back.
Yeah,
here.
yeah,
sure.
Like you just believe it and then as you
get older to challenge it or to question
it,
you're an asshole.
You know,
like you just can't,
don't,
don't challenge the Bible,
don't it's,
you know,
you can't do that.
I think there's a higher power.
I don't think it's that story,
but maybe a version of it.
Maybe not.
I don't know.
Who knows what it is,
but whatever it is,
it's not what l Ron Hubbard wrote.
It's not the one guy who wrote the most
books of anybody who ever wrote books,
ever scientology.
He wrote five books,
fiction.
He wrote more fiction.
Any person's ever lived.
He really did.
He did have one person that's ever lived
on the planet.
He wrote the most books.
That's incredible that they think that
that city,
right?
Fuck load.
Exactly a fuck load.
That's exact number.
Yeah.
That's a lot of books.
That's a good question.
James is gonna.
Pull that up.
We're gonna find out,
but he didn't know.
He wrote the hold the distinction.
She's the most prolific fiction author
ever in the history of the human race.
That's how stupid scientology is.
The guy who made up the most shit ever
also told the truth about the fucking
frozen ice cubes filled with Metta
volcanoes and volcanic and that's why
you get anxious.
You know,
it's a.
it's all so stupid.
Swimming across the board that's made up
stuff.
It's people making things up,
but you live and you die and no one
knows what happens when you die.
We'll all find out one day.
Hopefully.
Maybe.
Maybe we won't.
Maybe not.
Maybe it will become something that
doesn't think here it is.
Most published works by any author,
number one,
a whole Ron Hubbard.
Yeah.
One thousand and 84 books.
Jesus Christ.
Did he even fucking do a second draft on
he of them?
There's no way,
right?
This books are so bad to.
Have you ever publish them?
I don't know.
I don't think so.
I think he published them.
I mean he had been.
He published a lot of them in those.
A scifi magazines.
That was like a,
a big part of what he was doing
originally.
Wiki would get books published in those,
you know,
they were like Reader's digest.
Who would have these sipho last one was
published in 2006.
Then he died like the eighties.
Yeah,
they don't.
Well,
I don't think it was the eighties.
I think it was like the nineties.
What is it?
80 six was.
Well,
I'm sure they just found a bunch of shit
that he had laying around.
Stay the guy who was probably nuts.
He'll just sat down and just never see
like interviews or.
Do you ever watch those documentaries?
I'm fascinated by it.
I love.
Well,
I'll watch any documentary.
That's all I ever watch.
But those are particularly fascinating
because he looks crazy.
Oh,
he's crazy as fuck.
Lawrence Lawrence Wright wrote a
fantastic book called going clear and
that's what seems to make that or read
that one.
That was good.
You read it to him?
Yeah.
It's amazing.
Like when you hear about how nutty he
was,
like he was beyond crazy,
but it's one of those are usually people
that end up getting like a leader of
something.
They're always,
they're smart but crazy.
You know?
It's like a psychotic brilliance that
you can manage to get that many people
on board.
I mean,
they all dress like sea captains and
she's like,
yeah,
I'm like you,
you have a lot of metals dude,
and you have been highly decorated
officer in what?
Like,
well how about when Tom Cruz won that
gold medal for being awesome?
Holy Shit.
You fucking sit there and they were so
like tense.
Then you know both of those guys that
are about five foot one,
five foot two.
Holy Shit that made me laugh.
LRH lrh.
Yeah.
They salute to l Ron Hubbard,
the LRH.
This photo of them,
they'd salute the photo like it's
fucking like it's the flag.
Just thinking like one of your friends.
It's like real silly and Goofy,
like one of your craziest friends.
And then imagine his face or her face up
there and everyone just to.
Just to Andy Dick,
everybody.
There's a room full of people that give
money to.
That's.
It could be that.
It's not that much different.
No,
no,
it's not.
No,
I mean he is working with the size of
the fucking metal mean.
That shit makes flavor.
Flave look,
he saluted him.
He looks over and solutes and everybody
claps.
First of all,
look how beautiful that set is that
David Miscavige,
whatever that guy's.
She's just crisis genius.
That metal that he's wearing his whole
neck.
Some crazy,
some crazy cytology stuff.
That's the day with a youtube video.
It's fucking wonderful.
They're wonderful.
And there's a great one that a doc on
you can watch on youtube.
It's like scientology in me.
I think it was,
um,
it was,
it was from the BBC,
but it's really good.
It's this guy just track him down and
getting them.
It's a good one.
It's all clean water in clearwater,
Florida.
Yeah.
He was in,
but there was a summit was in London,
like their headquarters in London,
so it was pretty different when I'm
thinking.
I did see that one.
The clearwater one.
Yeah.
Well that's where the org people,
my family used to live there.
My Mom and my dad,
they lived in clearwater.
My sister still lives in Tampa.
There's still still down there.
Is that where you're from?
No,
no.
They moved there to escape the Boston
winters.
Now they're just trapped and trapped in
a sea of stupid.
A lot of Nice people down there,
but you know what?
I was just there in Tampa this past
weekend.
You know what it is?
It's all people from the northeast that
escaped.
That's all my whole show was like New
Yorkers,
Boston people,
Jersey people were tired.
People just get out of their fucking get
a job down there.
Fuck winter.
They just say fuck winter,
and they'd go to Florida.
I would do the same thing,
but I grew up in south Texas,
so like an admin.
It's 50 degrees out here and I'm like,
hey,
it's freezing.
I'm such A.
I couldn't deal with.
It will sound like Texas.
Like I dunno.
I love Houston spots.
It's got is it's got character.
If you're downtown and there's a lot to
do.
There's,
there's a,
there's a life down there,
you know that.
But then there are certain places that.
Yeah,
no,
it's not that fun.
Well,
I remember when I was in Boston,
there was essentially,
there was four big comedy scenes that
we'd heard about.
There was the Boston scene,
there was the New York scene,
there was a,
the La scene is kind of a San Francisco
seem a little bit,
but there was a Houston scene and the
Houston scene was because of Kennison
and Hicks Hicks.
That's where he was such a fan of his.
But like now they just have the Improv.
Like I,
I did a show at the Improv over
Christmas break and it's awesome.
It's fucking huge too.
It's a great venue,
but it's kind of in a weird part of town
and.
Yeah.
And it's just,
you mean black?
No,
it's out.
It's not really,
it's not a black part of town.
They only seem to book a lot of black
comedians.
Oh,
but no,
it's just off of the interstate.
It's an exit,
you know it.
It's just a weird part of town.
Like there's just nothing really around
it.
You're just kind of like hauling ass
down.
I 10 and then you take an exit and
there's the Improv.
So sad because that place,
the laptop in river oaks,
that's where I know that was the best.
I did my first CD there.
Oh really?
And Ninety nine was the shit,
it was the best club.
It was set up.
Perfect.
Now it was like a restaurant and I think
they're trying to get it where they can
at least open part of it up.
It's still there for comedy.
That's a different uh,
it's,
you know,
it's a restaurant,
a restaurant,
bar,
restaurant and that,
but as the stage still there and
everything.
No it's not,
but they're trying to,
you know,
like all the comedians are going,
hey,
give us a parking the.
Because there are a lot of good
comedians and he just,
you know,
and he wanted to be able to like do your
job and then try to do this on the side.
Like that's what I always enjoyed about
it,
but you know,
I'd have to go to the Improv or try to
get some stage time or sometimes I would
open up for my friends that were
musicians.
I would just do a set at their,
you know,
so at least I could get.
I could get stage time,
you know,
it's tough though.
Oh yeah.
So non ideal.
But I think,
you know,
it helped that I already had a job so I
didn't care as much.
Right.
You know,
like if I was depending on that as my
livelihood,
maybe I would have been more nervous.
But it was like,
yeah,
fine,
I'm going to have to work tomorrow is
one of the more frustrating things for a
young comedian.
There's,
they're starting out is to grow up a
town that doesn't have a scene play now
if you're in Cleveland or something like
that.
I don't know if Cleveland as a scene,
but it's fucking hard.
And these clubs like the Improv are
amazing to work out if you are
professional.
But yeah,
like I've done,
you know,
a couple of shows at the Improv here,
but it's only because maybe somebody
asked and they had to pull strings
because I'm not a name for a marquee,
you know,
and you.
And for the Improv you have to be like
trying to get on at the store or the
laugh factory.
And on like a Saturday night,
they're not going to just go,
hey yeah,
go do seven minutes.
Well,
they've sort of boxed themselves into
this whole though because you're the
only will they have these rooms that are
like 500 seats so they can't have open
mic nights because they can't keep the
room open because they can't eat all the
staff and everything.
It'll cost them too much money.
Yeah.
And as soon as you don't have open mic
nights then you're not developing new
talent.
As soon as you're not developing new
talent then you have to get all your ax
in from out of town and it just,
it kills the whole art form.
Like you have to have a place to start,
you know,
there's no one place where everybody
starts.
You can't say,
oh well they have open mic nights in La,
don't worry about it.
We'll start out in la.
No,
I mean when I came out here and I
started doing just.
I mean I'm,
I'm doing more writing,
but I still like doing,
I like trying to do stand up,
you know,
two,
three nights a week or something.
But it's hard to even get that
sometimes.
Like the laugh factory.
They're good to me over there.
And they'll give me a,
you know,
Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday,
you know,
one of those nights,
a flappers comedy in Burbank.
That's a great plot.
Great Club.
I've done.
Have you done the ha ha in North
Hollywood?
I have done that.
New One is fucking awesome.
It is awesome.
It's amazing.
It's perfect.
So I,
you know,
it's like,
but I have to find everything myself.
I don't rely on like my agent to do
that.
Like it's just,
you know,
I just want to get it sometime.
I still do that.
I just find everything myself to day.
You find that because I like sitting
there talking to him.
I'm like well you're not getting like I
get everything going to me shit.
So I'll just keep doing what I'm doing.
And especially like little clubs in
town.
I mean,
I mean all my bookings,
like if I do theaters and stuff like
that,
my agents do all that stuff.
But like if I do local spots around
town,
I have to fight.
Like Joey deals will call me up.
Listen to dog.
You got to do the fucking hot Hollywood.
He'll be taking bong,
his voice,
talking to you and the other girl.
Right.
And like we tell each other,
like comics will tell each other like
this is placing on Sundays in Santa
Monica that Neal Brennan has is supposed
to be awesome.
Yeah,
I keep seeing that on his,
uh,
he's promoting it west side comedy
theater.
I think it's called.
I haven't been there yet,
but I hear nothing but great things.
So that's what you hear,
you know,
you hear about cool spots.
Like I did the um,
the laugh factory in Long Beach than
that.
Um,
I heard that.
It's a great spot.
But the new ones also everything is
because of like just me,
like either hounding people or just a
friend
helping me out.
Like,
Hey,
do you want to open for me when I'm in
Long Beach or well this is an amazing
place.
If you're in La,
this is amazing place to work because
you really never have to leave.
You can work in just drive,
you know,
you can drive to Irvine,
drived Ontario,
you drive to break if you want to get
crazy,
you go to San Diego,
you know,
there's so many places to work around
here.
It's actually really pretty cool
considering like I moved here from
Houston,
you know,
it's just,
there's just no scene.
It just wasn't there.
It didn't exist so used to.
I'm telling you,
that used to be one of the best places.
When I first got there,
I first got to Houston in like 96 or 97,
somewhere around there,
maybe 90,
maybe 98 either way.
Um,
when I first got there I was like,
Holy Shit.
They had an open mic night that would
start at like eight and go till 2:00 in
the morning.
Yeah.
And the open mic night was in the bar
area where they had a small stage and
then they had the main stage with a main
room was,
which was fucking perfect.
It was the perfect setup and they had
all these really creative young local
comedians and they didn't have any
tolerance for hacks.
I was like,
this is just like Boston,
but like hot,
like hot weather,
but nobody can put their finger on why
it stopped because the club went under.
It's that easy to throw water on a fire
if they don't have anywhere to perform
and if there's no one seen like,
like somebody than try to take it.
Like I just felt like there would be
somebody that would make more of an
effort to try to get it right,
but who do it like?
I don't know.
I always thought that there would be
somebody that would try to bring it back
up again.
But.
Well they tried.
But you need like real resources.
You need a club,
you need a liquor license,
you need a,
you know,
you need the whole thing.
I mean they're idiots.
Can open bars.
How many bar owners do you know?
I don't know any idiots that owned bars.
Do you know it?
Idiots it on bars really a lot.
Really Talk to those idiots.
Tell him to put a stage up.
I don't know.
It's fucking.
It's not like anything else.
Like if you,
if you want to.
I guess being a musician was probably
just as difficult,
like how does that mean?
I mean,
I guess you can kind of make your own
mix tape and shit alone.
You don't need.
You don't need an audience to practice.
That's the difference between comedy and
other art forms.
You need an audience to practice to know
that.
Well,
that's one thing that I always enjoyed
about twitter.
You can kind of tell if something a joke
works or doesn't work on twitter by
people liking it.
Oh yeah,
definitely.
Now it's like,
okay,
that works,
so let me try it verbally.
You have a big following on twitter just
from being funny.
You know,
Bert Chrysler and I were talking about
you one day,
the podcast.
Why I say that message?
It was all my friends were like sending
me the link to it and like,
oh sweet.
Thanks.
Well that's a cool thing about twitter
is it's like there's a girl.
She calls herself slash lien.
God,
I love her.
She's hilarious.
She's up in Toronto.
It's the same thing.
She developed this giant following just
from being funny and I think that like
people like her myself,
I'm like Rob Delaney,
we all kind of jumped in at the exact
same time and I think,
I don't think that's possible now for
somebody.
I think there's too many people that
people always say that,
but it's like,
I don't want to start a podcast now.
Everybody's got a podcast,
but what,
how,
how about those guys?
We fucked girls.
Those girls that have that podcast
called guys we fucked.
I'd never heard of him.
He never heard of it.
It's like top 10 always,
and then it's only been around for like
a year.
They just have a really good podcast,
developed as big as following and then
shot up through the rankings,
like quit.
I don't think that podcasts I don't
like.
I'm,
I think that yeah,
a lot of people have them,
but I still would encourage people to
try.
But with twitter,
the only thing is,
you know,
it's just,
it was so new and different and
everyone's like,
who is that per,
you know it,
it was so new and exciting and now
there's all this other crap either
there's too many things,
periscope,
snapchat,
all the other,
all these other social media things and
at the time it was just like facebook
and twitter and I was at twitter doesn't
do it,
doesn't grow like it used to.
The amount of people that you get,
like people don't like you.
Some people used to get like massive
amounts of new followers like really
quickly.
But it's hard to do that now.
I think also like if you look at someone
and you look to see like,
like how many people do you follow?
I follow a lot of people and you read
every single shit.
I'm retarded.
I got something wrong with me.
I scan twitter constantly for
interesting stories and if someone
posts,
I'll look through their feed.
They post two,
three,
four interesting stories in a row and
boom,
I follow him.
I'm like,
you never know.
But how do you find them?
Just through somebody retreating number
or something.
Most of it is because they tweet things
to me.
That's a lot.
Okay.
So someone will tweet something really
cool to me and uh,
I retweet it.
Like what I've started doing,
I started doing a long time ago is when
people send me cool stuff,
I retweet it because it gives people an
incentive to send you more cool stuff
and they go,
hey,
retweeted me.
It's fine.
It's cool.
And like when I find their page,
like if someone retweets something or if
I retweet something someone sent me and
I find their page and they have a bunch
of cool shit on there,
I'll start following them.
And I think that just that way you
ensure that you have like sort of a
network of people that are distributing
interesting information,
sending it your way,
but he's a link.
Is it links to things?
Sometimes it's links to things that are.
Sometimes it's just a funny not apply to
you.
Oh yeah.
Sometimes it's funny reply sometimes.
It's just a funny post now how many
unfunny replies you get from people
trying to make you laugh.
Yeah.
You get those that's going to happen.
It's just cluttered and it's just,
Oh god,
sometimes it's so pull.
Yours is so humor based,
you know,
you're,
you're almost insulting me.
And I'm like,
what the fuck?
And they'll go,
it's getting,
you know,
like as a joke,
a joke.
I'm like,
no,
I can't.
Well you got to think there's a lot of
people that are just trying anything to
get a reaction from you.
They're standing out there hyping until
we get a signal back.
I mean,
but it's,
it's such an interesting concept that
people like,
like I did a panel at south by southwest
last year,
two years ago,
something like that.
And it was just it.
Yeah.
And it was just about like getting a
career out of it,
you know,
like how else would anybody have noticed
me outside of Houston?
Well that's how I noticed you.
I don't remember when I started noticing
you,
but I've been following you for.
How long have you been on twitter?
Since like 2009.
I the thing I've been following you for
at least two years,
at least two years.
And I don't know how long totally,
but I remember a guy tweeted one of your
things like to me,
I think someone tweeted something funny
that you said and I think I retweeted it
and then I started following you.
That's how I do it.
But it's really.
Yeah,
it's kind of,
it's word of mouth,
word of word,
but,
but you could still do that,
but I do think that's fast.
I,
that's what I love about twitter.
I think it's really fascinating that.
How else would anybody I've ever heard
of me if it wasn't for that particular
form of social media.
I just think there's too much now.
There's too many people.
There's too many extra things that I
don't think people are going to get
noticed that way that I lucked out and
got out of this.
Well,
there was that affect like the early
days of my space.
Do you remember the mindspace effect?
Like Tila,
Tequila and cook and all these people
got super famous,
like really quick.
Because once you know,
first of all you followed Tom because
everybody had a fall.
Tom,
from my space,
what the fuck is Tom Up to these days?
Just hope he's okay.
He's in Belize right now with gold
underwear on and fucking stacks of
champagne bottles next to him and big
fucking
bed.
Just bawling.
I mean,
how much money did you make from that?
Fucking stupid.
It made a shit ton of fucking facebook
guy.
Yeah,
I mean,
yeah,
that guy's made insane amounts of.
Wow,
that's impressive.
That's bizarre.
That's bizarre money.
He looks bewildered all the time too.
Like whenever he just woke up from a nap
to me always looks like he's worried
that someone's gonna kidnap.
I'm constantly.
You got that kind of money,
like don't you know that he's probably
had those threats.
Threats for sure.
When you're going to be billions of
dollars.
Billions and now he's got a new baby.
I believe it's him.
His wife just had a baby.
He's Christ,
but he takes pictures of everything is
why it was baby.
Look at me,
look at them.
Maybe it's like putting it out there,
like he's getting the jump.
Like,
uh,
what's his face?
Ben Shapiro was.
I'll put it out there first before.
Well maybe he's just surrounded by
fucking Spec ops guys just locked and
loaded,
ready to party.
It's a strange thing like facebook was
cool at first and then all of a sudden
when I started getting friend requests
from my mom's friends,
you know,
like then all of a sudden it was like
something else.
Well,
too many people get real weird online
and just started just digging into your
stuff and stalking you and look at
those.
Jenny Golan,
what she eats here every Tuesday.
It seems like if I go there on Tuesday,
maybe I'll find one.
I really enjoy your tweets.
You think he gets on my underwear.
It's like,
I don't know.
The people that think they know you
based on.
I think instagram was more that way.
Like I have twitter and instagram and
that's it.
I don't have the other things,
but
I would have like I'm gonna take an
instagram picture of you right now that
people will know that this happened
while we're actually doing the podcast,
talking about instagram,
so looking at me like
Bam.
Second.
Put that up.
If people go,
Hey,
but I've had people like I went to,
like I took a trip,
a road trip with friends to big Sur and
I went to big Sur.
I love big Sur shit up there so one of
my friends took a picture of me,
you know,
you get no cell reception and so we're
like on this side of the road,
I'm holding my phone.
I was like eating an apple and she took
a picture but it was so beautiful behind
me and I put that on instagram like,
oh,
I'm in big Sur.
And then I had these people that are
like,
you have to stay at Fenton.
That's where you have to stay and you
need to go eat.
And I'm like,
do you think I drove from La to big Sur
without a plan of where I'm going to
stay and what I'm going to do?
Like they're telling me what I need to
do.
Well,
they're just trying to help.
No,
it's in a different way.
It's like,
yeah,
you need to do this.
You don't know if it's like a deep
seated like as a kid being told that or
something that it's just so obnoxious to
me.
Yeah.
It's like I know I have a plan.
Don't worry.
I'm good.
You're a bit of a rebel.
I see what's now.
I think I'm probably an asshole.
A bit of an asshole is probably more
accurate.
I always assume it's.
We have very different reactions to the
same thing.
I always assume that it's people that
are in town that are trying to help me
out and steer me towards a good story.
You look at.
It's like they live in Vermont or
something.
They're just like,
they've been there once and telling me
what to do,
but don't you think that just trying to
steer you in the right direction.
You're like,
fuck you.
Don't tell me what to do.
Yeah.
No,
I think they're horrible people.
I think they're terrorist sympathizers
at the sympathizers,
yet they're all about isis.
See,
I always think they're just trying to
help out.
I think it's cool.
I enjoy it when people do that.
I even asked for suggestions.
I'll ask for.
That's different now.
I'll ask for suggestions.
It's just,
Hey,
I'm in big Sur and then it's like you
need to go eat here,
you need to stay here,
you know,
you have to do this,
you need.
And I'm like,
if you,
if you made it,
worded it in a way that was like,
I don't know where you're staying,
but I could tell you like I stayed here
at one time and it was fantastic.
It was more of like the telling me what
to do.
You think that people say that when
something's awesome like,
dude,
you need to check this out.
I find sometimes people do it to let me
know they've been places.
Does that ever happen?
You know what I mean?
Like it's like kind of um,
Brag.
Almost like a humble brag.
It is like that or a Oh,
that jacket.
Yeah.
That.
And then tell me the name of the jacket,
like the brand or whatever.
Like I have that jacket too.
Do you react?
Is it like men telling you to go
somewhere and do things?
Do you,
do you need to blow your nose?
Yeah,
I need to blow my nose,
my allergies.
My claritin has not kicked in yet.
Um,
what do you have allergies to?
It's usually when it rains,
whatever it kicks up.
It's like pollen,
ragweed,
like all that shit oil,
plenty of oil.
But it's not,
it's not that men actually.
It's typically women that do it.
Brilliant.
Yeah.
Oh No.
Men Don't really actually bothered me
that much.
I mean that if somebody will write
something sexual or whatever,
I'm like,
ah,
thanks.
It doesn't,
I don't get offended by it.
It just thinks like gives a shit
I,
but I've see you.
It is funny when you click on that,
you can click on their page and you'll
see.
It's like the pictures,
you know,
the guy and his wife and three little
kids and he's like,
I want to smell your vagina.
You're like,
I'm so glad you're married.
And a father.
I just imagined my dad doing that.
Growing up.
He would have had instagram.
God,
he wouldn't have.
No,
no,
not yours.
Not My dad.
He would probably,
he would have been more of the,
you know,
like when you're a kid,
you're like,
you walk in your Dad's watching tv and
it's like there's just tits on the
screen here.
I'm going to get on there,
I don't know,
skinemax or whatever these flipping
through and then I walk in and surprise
him and he,
oh no,
I was just trying to figure out those
goddamn remote,
like,
fuck,
no,
I'm not doing that.
That's what he grew up in a different
era.
If he grew up today,
the,
your era definitely formed you in a way.
I see.
My parents were like,
my dad and I were like,
well,
40 years younger than my parents.
My Dad's no longer with us,
but my.
Yeah,
they were just older people that had
kids later in life.
Well,
there was still banging it out late in
life.
That's good.
Yeah.
They were like married for I think like
15 years before that.
My sister.
Wow.
Yeah.
But the downside would be like my sister
and I'd go,
hey,
we want to go to California,
go to Disneyland.
Disney,
you know,
and I know we've been there a million
times,
just say all.
No,
that's makes me sad as a dad
with my kids,
we always did shit,
but we were.
We grew up on the water so we had like,
oh yeah,
we always ended with beach boat,
sailboat.
We had all the fun stuff.
It's not like we were in the Gulf that
water
oil spills up that motherfucker
now probably a lot more.
I don't think there were so many when I
was a kid.
They weren't digging,
I'm sure as much.
I don't think so.
I went to Santa Barbara recently after
the big oil spill in the Gulf.
Whenever I see those fucking things out
in the water,
I say,
well that's a ticking time bomb.
Right?
So that's going to fuck up eventually.
And then this beautiful beach,
it's going to have oil all over it.
Well the odds of it fucking upper
actually.
I mean you think about how many rigs are
in the water and how many spills there
have actually been.
It's,
you know,
it's,
it's not the odds of all of those
things.
Having a a,
a spill is pretty.
It's fairly low,
fairly low and it's,
but it's always like human error.
It's just they're not hiring and it's
always bp and I always,
I actually think it's always bp.
They don't hire the right people.
It's not always other companies with the
last big BP oil spill to cut corners,
like the fact that they cut corners and
the way they constructed it because they
were behind budget,
but exactly the amount of they have
versus the amount of accidents that
occur and the devastation that occurs
because of the accidents.
That's one way of looking at it,
but the other way of looking at it is
when those accidents do occur,
the fucking catastrophic damage is so
devastating that each one of those
things is a ticking time bomb.
And how long have they been doing it?
Well,
they've only been doing those offshore
oil drills for like 30 or 40 years I
think.
I don't think it's been more than that.
I think it's been.
I think it's just over 40.
I think so.
So to me,
I look at it like nuclear power.
There's only been a couple of nuclear
accidents,
but those accidents are a fucking crazy
like Fukushima.
Everybody's sort of forgotten about it,
but every.
I still check on the news or on
Fukushima because the mainstream news is
completely stopped paying attention to
it,
but if you pay attention to it,
if you go and search out,
it's off cluster fuck over there.
It's really bad and it's not getting any
better.
Like anytime soon.
No,
I grew up in the town I grew up and
actually had a nuclear power plant.
Well,
yeah,
and then riggs everywhere.
It was just.
I'm surprised I don't have like a
fucking arm guard out of my head.
I have a buddy who was a bone cancer
because he grew up next to a golf course
and really fucking golfing and gives you
a bunk answer.
No,
the pesticides they would use on the
golf course.
Keep the weeds down.
Sure.
Sank into the wells and so they had well
water.
Everybody on his fucking block.
Our cancer,
like literally everybody got cancer
crazy.
Well my dad,
I mean he.
He died from cancer,
but he also worked at a chemical plant
for 37 years,
so now you can't tell me that,
that didn't like play into him getting
diagnosed with cancer.
Just smelling chemicals all day long,
like there's just no way.
And I know all the people that he's
worked with and how many people have
ended up,
you know,
getting some fucked up kind of cancer.
Oh Man.
Oh terrible.
Do you feel like um,
there's a,
there's a weird thing going on with
instagram and social media and stuff
like that,
that there's this new sort of intimacy
that's very difficult to navigate.
That's what I was saying that people
like sort of contact.
Do you like they know you or they,
they reach out to you and give you
suggestions.
Like they know you there.
There's an intimacy that people have
with people that like them or follow
them that you didn't have to really
handle 20,
30 years ago.
People have access to.
Yes.
You have access to them if you're so
inclined and you know,
like I'll get people because now like
with Instagram,
you can direct message on instagram and
twitter,
you know,
read those though.
Um,
you know,
I'll see.
Sometimes I'll click and I could see
what it is and if it's just something
I'm like,
man,
just I've already seen it or I can't sit
there and accept everything because then
everybody would keep.
Yes.
You know,
sending things.
Um,
how many instagram followers to like
57,000.
That's a lot of fucking people.
If they all hit you at once.
Yes.
So I try to help addicts together on a
daily one or two.
Not as much as I should.
That's the right thing.
I,
I'm kinda disappointed at my level or
yeah.
Or if somebody else send me like the
same day,
I'm like,
I've seen that.
That's not
shame on you when they get a google
image.
Dick.
Yeah.
They're like Google image,
somebody else's Dick.
And I'm like,
don't do that.
Guess what?
After this podcast,
they're common.
Thank you Vinnie Johnson.
Night five following up right now.
You're the camera's clicking away.
You written on unzipping.
I don't want to filter on them either.
No.
Filters do prefer semi rigid placid.
I just find it entertaining that anybody
would do it.
I actually,
I can't ever say that it's different for
guys.
Like if everyone's like sending you
boobs,
like you're going to be happy with
boobs.
Yeah,
but like,
I don't know any girls,
they're like stoked.
When a guy sends him a dick pic.
It's got to be some.
I mean I get,
trust me,
my phone is filled as some of the
negative shit you've ever seen.
Like the gift,
Jif pictures,
videos.
I have a healthy sense of humor,
but I've never gotten a picture of a
Dick and been like,
wow,
that I want to meet the guy attached to
that.
Like I've never felt that way,
but you're not a whoa.
Maybe that's it.
Maybe I could try to work on that.
But it's weird.
Like sometimes I'll,
I'll get a photo like from someone I
have no idea who they are and it's just
their vagina and I'm like,
okay.
And you're just like,
well that's not something you would do.
Right.
But you knew you wouldn't like find some
musician that you really liked and send
them a picture.
But there's girls who do that.
God bless them,
you know,
they got free time,
they're proud.
But I think the kind of girl that would
send you a photo of her vagina,
it was a kind of girl would love a dick
pic.
Like all right,
you know,
it's good manners.
Bayview give some.
I give some.
I can't say that I would ever.
I mean I would never do that.
It's just not.
I just the idea of eat me even doing it
is hilarious to me.
Like okay well let me go like and then
like taking a bunch to decide which one
you liked the most because you know,
it wasn't a one take vagina pick really
bad.
If you get a vagina pick and it's like
that sort of frosty foggy photoshop
thing.
Filter.
It looks like a camera shot or
something.
Like what the.
Is that your,
is that a real vagina or is this some
anime?
Send me that in 1977 filter.
Just fucking playboy from the early
eighties.
You know these,
these weird images,
like sometimes people will take pictures
and you look at the picture you like,
that is not even you fucking Dane Cook
has done that a couple of times.
I've looked at his images.
I'm like,
what kind of filters?
Using buddy,
like what's going on here?
He cooks.
He is a pretty a hilarious instagram
page for all the wrong reasons.
Should word it properly.
Yeah.
No,
just him
without his shirt on or something.
And then this long paragraph of how
blessed and
at some point I'm like,
if he is really making a joke,
that's amazing,
but he's not hashtag blessed.
Blessed.
I can't even do it.
It's a joke.
Maybe the entire thing has been
following mice.
Just randomly type in his name and then
just because I'm like,
let me see what this is.
And then it never.
It never doesn't make me laugh.
It's funny.
Every single time I've seen some good
ones.
There's a lot of people that are fall
looked out there just to just say
ridiculous shit.
So I follow them for that.
Just hoping they're going to say
something stupid.
I liked the people that will post things
like to show you how great their life
is.
It's the humble brag kind of way.
Like I remember this one girl was like
trying to show that her son had straight
a's on his report card and so like the
way that she was holding it was also to
show that she was wearing a rolex and
shit fucking ring on.
But it was like perfectly in the frame
that way.
But that is amazing that you just did
that and I know exactly what you're
doing but you think you're outsmarting.
Everyone is so proud of my son.
Hashtag let my son and then just
weird little monkeys in that regard.
Peacocking monkeys and in some things
it's like I,
my mom is like the best at this because
if my sister will send like a picture of
my nephew on his first day of school,
you know,
everybody likes to do that first day of
school lunchbox backpack and standing in
front of the front door and my mom were,
will reply back because it'll be like a
group email and she'll go,
oh,
you need to get those fingerprints off
the front door.
You have fingerprints.
Like she looks past the picture to see
what's behind that.
My sister's front door has glass
fingerprints everywhere.
Like I kind of love that.
And if you look at everyone's picture
and do that,
it's pretty hysterical.
Like,
what's in the background?
I love that.
It makes me laugh every time was one of
the saddest pictures I ever saw was this
girl.
She had her ass up in the year and uh,
you know,
she's like posing style and then the
background,
the lower left corner is a baby crawling
around like a little toddler.
It's like,
Whoa,
that's dark.
Like you could see them like in the
hallway in the lower left corner of the
picture,
like Oh God,
it's so like,
it's disgusting.
But then I also like,
um,
there's certain people that will post
the picture where maybe they're on the
beach.
Okay.
And they're looking down at the water
and they'll put some like inspirational
quotes,
you know,
something that's like,
Jesus be with,
well blah blah blah.
All I'm going is who the fuck to that
took that picture.
You had to ask somebody to do that and I
guarantee you again,
wasn't a first tight eat.
Like it was not the first take.
Like they had the gun to get up at rock,
a little Morgan,
my jawline to look sharp and look like
really smart.
And I that that's actually my favorite
thing on instagram.
I just like looking at people's pictures
when like what are you trying to get
across to everybody?
Like knowing,
knowing the people are going to see it
and like I know what you're doing,
but some people can do it and it works.
Like,
like,
you know,
who I followed,
I legitimately enjoy is the rock.
The rock gets it too.
I think that he gets,
he's having fun,
having fun.
I actually,
I liked him but he's inspirational.
Like he'll,
he'll post like stuff about him getting
up at 5:00 in the morning to work out
before getting to the set and I don't
feel like he's bragging at all.
I feel like he's inspiring people.
Like he inspires me.
Yeah.
Actually that kind of stuff we'll get,
you know.
Okay.
Yeah.
Get to the gym to,
you know.
Yeah.
It is kind of a.
But I don't feel that he's full of Shit.
I've never felt like he was full of
Shit.
I even when he was fucking wrestling,
he got it.
He's wrestling.
It's funny,
you know,
he's playing a character and I have
always liked him.
I thought he was by all accounts.
He's a really great guy.
Everybody that I've ever met that met
him,
worked with him or knew him.
So there's a really nice guy just having
fun.
Have you ever met him before?
Yeah,
I met her a long time ago.
I've met him before he was the rock.
He wasn't really that famous.
I met him.
I was on MTV for one of those spring
break things in Mexico,
like Cancun or something like that.
Speaking.
I just said hi to him.
It's just a big guy,
but he wasn't big.
He is now.
He's just like,
he looked like a regular athlete now
he's just as fucking gigantic muscled
guy.
I can't remember what it was and maybe
it was like some after Emmy per after
Golden Globe party or whatever,
and I saw him and he was.
He's a fucking wall.
A huge dude.
He's like 2:50 all muscle and no fast.
Completely.
Just totally hooked.
Yeah,
he's,
I like him.
He's a nice guy.
He seems like a nice guy,
but it's frozen chicken.
I'd fuck him.
How about that?
Nope.
I said it.
I like it.
Yeah.
He's one of the few guys that poses in
front of a private jet that doesn't
bother me.
You know,
like please God,
that's such a heady time.
I've been on a private jet.
I'm like,
oh,
I could never do it.
Really.
I couldn't do it and I would feel so
Douchey,
moved,
but
velvet suit and again see that someone
had to take that photo,
but it doesn't bother me.
We own the night.
Thank you.
Golden Globes for a spectacular evening.
Wheels up admiring me.
Bound ballers.
Set.
Here I come.
Let's shoot ball.
So hard.
Hashtag velvet blazer.
That is a.
That is a massive potential for Douche
involved in that photo.
It was overwhelming.
Yet it doesn't come off.
Douchey for whatever reason.
For 30 3:00 AM.
See that
cardio before I head to work?
Yes.
Hashtag Jesus needs a cup of them
loaded.
Let's roll.
I mean it doesn't bother me.
He's just one of those guys.
He can get away with it.
Oh,
only 300.
19,000 likes.
That's what does he have?
Like 50 million followers or something
like that?
I
think I have like 800,000 step video of
what happened was instagram account with
when you have 8 million followers,
when you post something,
what happens?
Just explodes.
This person's phone go crazy.
Oh,
well you have the fucking turned off or
turned on.
Oh my God.
That would be insane.
Have you ever been with somebody that
has a lot of followers and then you see
a notification pop up that they had a
line here that some.
Have you ever been around somebody that
Doug Benson used to have that he shut it
off,
but just to have that like,
oh my God,
look at the phone.
Oh my God,
that's insane.
Oh my God.
That is insane.
Like a soccer accounts to six soccer
sports teams kind of thing.
Oh my God.
That is fucking insane.
For the phone.
It was like a waterfall.
It'd be a great way to test the battery.
That battery life is just shrinking top.
Just like a Gigantic v eight engine when
you stomp on the gas.
That is insane.
That is amazing.
Wow.
Rich kids of China just do that.
Well,
any rich people?
Instagram,
like rich kids of Dubai,
like those.
Those things are hilarious.
God,
that's amazing.
Strange and not have the notification
thing.
I just don't.
I don't know.
I don't care enough.
I guess maybe I should.
Well,
it's just not smart.
Phone was constantly.
I mean my phone if it.
If you text me,
I assume I like you and I want to talk
to you and that's what essentially it is
reaching out and contacting you.
And I have to always,
but I don't even keep that.
I don't keep a notification even for a
text you don't know because of buzz.
Your phone isn't buzzard some texts and
everything turned off.
So because I don't like being rude when
I'm in front of like,
like when it's,
if,
if it was an emergency,
you know,
like don't call you or something.
Huh?
Well everybody must know then you,
you can't text Jenny and hover text you
right back.
Well I feel like,
you know,
like if you're at dinner with your
friends or something and people lose
that friend that just won't put the
fucking phone down.
That's rude.
So I just,
I,
so if anything I'm doing,
I always try to keep my phone.
You ever see a Anthony Bourdain's show?
Parts unknown?
Uh,
actually I,
I caught part of it the other night.
Great fucking show.
But anyway,
he has these friends that he turned me
onto that are in Montreal.
They owned this restaurant called Joe
beef and it's fucking fantastic
community is one of the greatest
restaurants in the history of the world
and they did this episode with these
guys were,
they were on the,
they went ice fishing and they set up
this ice fiscal because they're in
Montreal,
so it's cold as fuck.
So they set up this shack on a lake and
inside they had like a full gourmet
meal.
They set up like the whole deal,
like beautiful tablecloths,
great food and hold you.
And they were talking about like,
how do you set up like,
what do you,
what do you have rules when you go to
dinner?
And he was like,
rule number one.
I shut my phone off because I,
I'm,
you know,
I want to have a good conversation.
You want to be a good dinner guest?
I want to be someone who's like,
how?
How many people do that?
How many people shut their phone off?
Just shut your fucking phone off.
Very few times you go to a restaurant,
you see people just staring at our phone
with another person's over there staring
at their phone,
right?
Jesus love texting each other.
Family of four and the kids had even had
head phones on and they're just staring
and you're like,
your communication skills are going to
suck ass when you're older because no
one's talking to you.
You don't want to talk to them.
No one's forcing you to.
Well,
I have a folder on my phone that's all
for my kids.
My kids,
their little fingerprints open my phone
up and they'll like if I,
if I leave my phone around,
they grab it because they think it's fun
to take your fingerprint.
Five and seven at the little one.
And so they'll go to the folder and if I
don't let them,
if I don't let him play with the phone
like,
no,
no.
Come on,
let's just have a conversation.
You can just pull.
Can I just play with your phone?
Like,
no you can't.
Can I play with your phone?
No,
I just said you can't definitely please
put your phone.
No,
you can't play with the phone.
Let's just hang out and talk.
That hovers over your head as an option
to talking to your parents.
It's so attractive that they just can't.
What can I play with your phone now?
No,
you just asked 30 seconds ago.
You little fuck.
Come on
and we'll say that but it.
But it is.
I mean like I like I saw kids actually
will walk in just a group of kids where
my,
uh,
where the gym is that I work at it.
We're like Fairfax high school is so I
go to this little boxing gym and there's
an alleyway where the kids will walk and
so like when you're in there you can
watch them walking after school and
every single one it's just buried in
their phone.
They don't look up there.
Just some lady walked right into me at
the airport the other day.
I just stood like,
like she going to walk right into me.
Bam.
Just wasn't even looking.
Just hoping that people would just get
out of her way.
I was like,
this is hilarious.
This lady is just walking forward while
texting.
All I did was stop.
I was like,
okay,
what's going on here?
Like she can't just like go to the side
and just how do you walk in text?
I ended with an airport.
Yeah,
and plus there's fucking chairs like
everywhere obviously bitch one of the
gates.
Well how many times you've been on the
road and you'd watch someone's swerving
and you go,
this fucker's texting.
I know what you pull up beside them and
see the light of their phone
illuminating your face is there or when
it's like you're at a red light,
light turns green and they're still
sitting there because there is somebody
has to honk and then we'll.
This again.
I think these things go back to what I
was talking about earlier.
That media I think is too compelling for
our natural response systems or natural
instincts and reward systems that are in
place for people like this is too much
going on there.
It's too fun.
It's to peek in there,
you know,
like,
but if you ever get like where you were
on a long flight and there was no Wifi
or whatever and you couldn't wait to
play with your phone [inaudible],
you know,
sometimes five hour flight you.
And then when you're finally in a chair
and you're comfortable,
you're like,
check mark
when you go to Australia,
16 hours.
Anything can happen.
We know about that lady that texted that
joke about aids.
Well that was,
we were talking about what you're
talking about.
You did.
It was like one of those people that
would do that.
She would text funny shit like
controversial.
Try to be funny,
trying to be rude.
And she texts this joke about I'm going
to Africa,
hope I don't get aids.
Just kidding.
I'm white,
lol.
Which I read and it was funny.
I laugh,
she's fucked.
I mean she got chicken,
did she got shit canned and now she
works for one of those,
uh,
like sorta like draft kings,
one of those kinds of companies.
There are fees involved in another
company.
Why are they getting shaken?
The owners,
they got too greedy with their
commercials.
Oh really?
Now because everybody that did fantasy
football and shit like that were,
you know,
all the cool dudes.
If I go to hooters on Saturday morning
to draft my team,
you know,
that kind of thing.
And I think that it just got to like in
your face like,
yeah,
we're gambling,
we don't give a shit.
Here's our ad for it.
Like you can't do that,
but it should be legal.
It should,
it should totally be legal.
But the reason they're in trouble I
think because they get too greedy.
Is that why they're in trouble,
Jamie,
you know about all that stuff.
Is that whether in trouble sort of sort
of there being,
from what I understand there's,
they're being a little bit deceptive and
what's actually going on
from what I've read,
one percent of the people that actually
play are winning like 99 percent of the
money.
Smart ones like the rest of the world.
And have some algorithms used to be a
professional poker players online.
Sort of.
Oh,
so they've figured out how to do it with
math.
Yeah,
exactly.
I would not be able to do that.
Well,
I used to have the sponsor called
lumosity and lumosity is like their
brain games and they're supposed to like
increase your Iq.
They're kind of interesting.
They're supposed to increase.
There are games that you play that can
actually accelerate learning or help you
learn or make your brain work better or
something like three's the.
There's some number games they're
supposed to help you.
Chess,
chess.
It helps your brain while these people
got greedy with their claims and now
they're fucked and they go.
They just had a judgment against him for
like millions of dollars have payback.
Yeah,
because they were saying shit like it
could.
I guess they had alluded to the idea
that it would help stave off early
Alzheimer's.
Yeah.
I had read something about that because
there was different games and there was
something that was
like if you're driving somewhere and
there was a thing like drive with oven
mitts on or you know.
Yeah.
Like it was like do something different.
Like you always go to the grocery store,
you go on this.
I'll start.
I'll start in the middle.
So as people get older,
as you get older,
you really get set in your ways and so
you know,
to go this way to this place,
go the other way.
Oh,
how fucked up.
But something to just kind of jar your
brain to make you.
Oh,
okay.
Now I have to think because usually
after a while you're just a robot if
you're doing it exactly the same damn
thing.
And so different grocery store you go
to,
you know,
like that kind of thing.
And it was my mom's.
I told her about this and she goes,
oh,
well,
okay,
well tell me.
And I said,
well,
like when you go to the grocery store,
I said,
um,
go a different route,
take you know,
take the seventh street and go around
doing that.
I was like,
okay,
well when you have the best,
but when you go and you always start at
produce,
this is go start at the bread.
I only other said,
well that's just stupid.
I'm not doing.
I was like,
well I'll buy and I'll see in the
nursing home and always
trying to help people.
It's weird that people have that thing
where like patterns or they actually
sort of like limit the possibilities
that your brain has to consider.
So your brain sort of atrophies almost
like,
you know,
like not lifting weights are not
exercising or something along those
lines.
Like I mean like I have to go exercise.
That helps me.
Like it makes me.
Oh yeah,
that helps.
That helps a lot.
But do you do that before shows?
Do you find that like if you have an
important show that exercising sort of
leaving it?
I try to do.
For me it's cardio like hard cardio or
do like elliptical machine or something
like that for like a half an hour before
show of,
Oh I feel so much better.
It's almost,
it's almost like I know it doesn't work
that way,
but it's almost like I got clean out my
brain pipes.
Like I'm just flushing the system blood.
I know it doesn't really work that way.
I actually think it does because if you
ever had a show where you know you've
got somewhere and you're like,
okay,
I have to,
I have to take a nap because I've been
going,
going to take a nap,
you wake up to go to the show,
and I'm like,
I just,
you know,
just woken up.
I just don't feel as sharp as if I,
you know,
when I go work out and then I'm just
going,
I'm like,
I'm ready to go.
Then.
Yeah.
I don't know know exactly what the
mechanisms are that are going on inside
the mind when you're exercising,
but there's something that the mind gets
exercised too as well as the body
because your mind has to move the body,
like you think of exercise being a non
mental thing because oh,
your just immediate.
Just feel good and working out,
lifting weights,
but there's something that's going on
while your brain is forcing your body to
do these movements.
You're,
you're exercising willpower,
you're exercising like determination and
focus.
There's always things that are going on
that I think accentuate intellectual
pursuits.
Yeah.
If that makes any sense.
No,
it does,
I mean like I,
I go to this boxing gym and I don't
actually spar with people but it's just
one on one me and my trainer,
but heel pads on his hands and he,
I have to do combinations so I have to
think and I know when I start getting
really tired and I need to contribute a
water,
like I'll start forgetting.
I can watch myself be fresh and then I'm
like,
oh Whoa,
whoa.
Yeah,
you told me to waive.
Okay,
hang on,
go back at it again.
Let me get a drink of water.
But it,
I like it because it makes me think
while I'm doing something right,
I still have to concentrate on.
Exactly.
You know,
whatever it is I'm doing.
So there is something to it.
I agree with that.
Any,
any sort of exercise that you have to
think about?
Things like they say handball is really
good for the mind,
like yeah,
yeah,
racketball,
handball,
things on those lines with that ball's
coming.
You don't know where it's gone.
You have to really anticipate what's
happening.
Yeah,
I would imagine tennis would be the same
thing.
Like because your,
your hand eye coordination involved with
fast motion calculations,
the spin of the ball,
the ball's bouncing here goes a lot of
different things you have to sort of
trick your mind into getting engaged
with.
Now.
I agree with that.
I mean it's,
I don't know.
I don't know like what Causes
Alzheimer's?
Like what,
what's the cause of it?
Is it just.
I think it's a genetic issue,
is it?
Believe so.
I believe it's the people who have a
genetic propensity for it.
I wonder if people that just do like
when people get old and they're just in
their recliner all fucking day long and
that's watching the same shit.
Like you're not challenging yourself
ever.
Yeah.
I wonder if that factors in at all.
I think it certainly could factor in,
but people that have it,
it is a disease.
Um,
people that I know,
I have a friend who's girlfriend's dad
has it and they have to go visit and
it's just,
he's just barely there.
He's just,
he's completely out of it.
And he was an interesting podcast,
I think it was radio lab where they're
talking about they were trying to
repopulate the whooping crane.
The whipping cream was like in danger of
extinction.
And one of the things that they had done
was they tried to come up with new
migration paths for these animals.
I think I read something about that.
Well,
this lady had a bird feeders in her yard
and he's whooping cranes,
had come to her yard to use the bird
feeders and you know,
they were setting up these bird feeders
and interacting with them and the
scientists that had spent so much money
and so much time trying to engage these
whooping cranes into forming these new
migration pass.
We're trying to get her to stop doing
it,
trying to get her to stop feeding the
birds because these birds,
they will.
They don't want them.
They want them to be wild.
They don't want them to rely on people.
And also because these patterns were
predictable,
people would find them in the people
would.
Some people were shooting the whooping
cranes and should.
They had lost a few of them and it's bad
fucking ungodly amounts of money trying
to repopulate these birds,
but her husband had Alzheimer's like
real bad and the only thing that would
get them excited was birds.
So he would be out there with her and he
would see the birds.
He,
we'd all look,
look,
there he is right there.
And she said like for that brief moment,
while these birds were there,
he would be back and she'd be able to
engage them and talk to them,
but when the birds were gone,
he just drifted away right back.
And he was gone.
And so she was like,
fuck you.
I'm hanging out with my husband with the
birds.
It was weird,
you know,
that's pretty.
Yeah.
It's actually kind of incredible.
I mean,
I remember like when my dad,
before he died,
this real fun story,
but my head,
my mom was like,
you know,
just,
they were frustrated with each other.
You know,
he's just riddled with cancer.
She's trying to help.
He's pissed and they never fought.
They never ever.
So it was weird to see them that way.
But then if somebody came that he didn't
know,
he would come back like it was like,
you're a new person.
It's not the same shit.
You know,
like as soon as somebody brand new came
in,
like if it was a nurse or somebody that
he didn't know,
I would watch him just immediately come
back,
you know,
like I don't know if he was trying to be
more hospitable or if it was like what
it was,
but just you would watch them just like,
it could just switch and he would be
nice.
Well I think novelty,
new things,
new new experiences,
new places,
all those things stimulate areas of our
brain that we kind of take for granted.
Like I like doing things that I suck at.
That's one of the things that I really
liked doing or like doing things that
I'm not good at it.
I'm new at them and because because I'm
new at,
am I getting obsessed with it like you
want to be good at,
but you're probably competitive to a
fault of issues.
I'll be sweating at a board game or
something.
Like just probably why it was real bad
when I was young.
I'm way better at it now way better
because now I understand what it is.
Back then I just,
I just would be overwhelmed by the demon
and I would just,
I just needed to win,
you know,
find a way to win.
Right.
But I'm just new things,
like even things that aren't
competitive.
Well I guess archery can be competitive,
but I just do it like sort of as
practice.
But I'm obsessed with it.
I fucking it just because I suck at it
for whatever reason.
Like when I'm practicing it's just
becomes my entire focus and these new
things like that.
Like Yoga is another thing.
I fucking suck at it,
but I was doing it.
I can't do it.
How come you can't do it?
You only tried it once.
I'm not flexible.
Well that's because you got to stretch
what the fuck?
Kind of logic.
But I suck.
That's like saying yeah I tried playing
football but I'm not good at it.
But try to move around a lot more.
Okay.
So that's why you go really wasn't I
like feeling like I'm doing,
I like to go jog,
I liked,
you know,
like that's not enough moving about.
Yeah.
Well that's part of the whole practice
of it is practice being still holding
poses.
My point,
my point is I'm not good at it but.
So I'm obsessed with it so when I do it
I just,
it just becomes like this overwhelming
thing for me.
But I concentrate on it all the time and
I'll do it a couple days a week and for
the other days that I'm not doing,
I'm thinking about it a lot of time.
That's interesting.
I think that's why I like,
well I kind of stand up those up for me.
Oh yeah.
Stand up really does that for me because
I get,
I always get a little nervous before a
go,
you know,
like you and if it works,
and if it doesn't you figure out what
joke didn't work,
why it did,
you know,
you should scrap it,
change it.
Should I.
But I,
I,
that's one thing I really love about
standup is it does like Jeremy,
you know,
it makes me like,
like how you feel when you get off stage
and you're like all psyched up and shit.
Like I love that feeling of being
nervous and you know,
onstage and that always is very like
rewarding to me.
Stand was one of the few things is still
challenging in that way.
All these years later,
26 plus years later for me.
But it's also because I write new stuff.
That's the key is practicing new
material,
having new material,
constantly writing.
If you don't do that then you get
trapped and if you get trapped with an
act like we all know those older comics
that have been around for 50 fucking
years or whatever and they have that act
where they're doing like Reagan
impressions,
smoke issues,
Claritin,
claritin.
No,
it hasn't kicked in yet.
I took it on.
The way here are alerted to anything
else?
Cats,
dogs,
cheese,
milk,
nothing.
No.
Just flying through the air.
I don't even know what it is,
Huh?
No,
I know.
It's like a Paul.
Every time it rains,
that's when it happened.
So it's whatever's kicked up like
ragweed pollen is.
It's seasonal times a year.
Yeah.
Did you get it in Houston as well?
Huh?
Just different times a year in Houston
is different out here.
I've actually had a worse out here,
which is weird.
That is weird.
Yeah.
I don't know if it's the climate,
like I was in a really humid climate.
I don't know if there's just something
else maybe that I'm allergic to that I
don't know,
but I've noticed that because my eyes
get a little burn,
you know,
and I'll get like that,
that just real bread.
I could feel like everything's draining.
That's interesting because a lot of
people move to like dry desert climates
like Arizona to try to avoid.
Believe me,
I know,
it's weird.
I don't know what it is,
but it's been worse since I've been in
La.
So Houston in the summer is one of the
most bizarre environments.
You're just breathing water.
He like,
yeah,
everything's just.
It's wet.
Yeah.
I really feel like you could drain your
100 degrees and 100 percent humidity.
It's just the windows outside.
You Walk Up,
you're wearing sunglasses,
they fog up and everything.
Your your sunglasses fog up,
your.
Your clothes instantly stick to you.
Like to concerts.
We'll start filming a flimsy.
It could be at one of those like stiff,
you know,
t shirts.
All of a sudden it's real flimsy.
It stuck to you,
but it's really good for your skin.
Is it?
Yeah.
Chicks to young looking for a long time
out there.
Just stay where they're moist.
Facially
skin was don't mean the other way.
Moist.
Your skin,
your facial skin stays moist.
Does that make sense?
My line,
my bacon things.
I use lotion.
Yeah.
Well that helps too.
Yeah,
that's a good move.
I do that,
but I think that uh,
the environment,
like the dry air environment is bad for
your skin.
It definitely is because I know like
when those moments during the summertime
out here when it's just fucking that
just gnarly heat,
that desert heat heat.
Oh my God.
And it's like,
my skin is like drinking the lotion that
I've put on it.
It's like how my skin already dried out
again,
you know,
like you're just sitting there just.
It's pretty,
pretty.
Not Fun.
But I like it out here better.
What do you like about here?
But more open minded more.
Oh No,
smart.
Do.
Oh,
you know,
I like doing all the standup stuff and
writing and it's different because I
moved out here.
Yeah.
Career wise.
So I love my career so that makes it,
you know.
So.
And plus the weather's usually always
nice out here.
I liked the beaches,
I like to surf.
I like to,
you know,
it's fun.
There's two things I don't like out
here.
One,
the overpopulation.
Yeah,
it's ridiculously over.
Traffic sucks.
Traffic sucks that stuff and to.
There's.
Go ahead.
She's,
she's
tucking away.
No,
I'm just like throwing all my fucking
tissues.
It's really impressive that the um,
the other thing is there's this
disingenuous aspect of the entertainment
industry.
This is shallow,
weird sort of actor.
He thing that I think is a product of
people having to audition.
So you're constantly having to get
people to like you,
so you put on this sort of fake behavior
and then you become a part of whatever
click or whatever pattern that you think
is like in the vogue in popular,
you know,
like how many people called Caitlyn
Jenner a hero and you know,
like it's,
you know,
you're in,
you're in with the right,
the right sensibilities to.
Right.
You know?
Yeah.
Even on your head,
you could be like,
with Kony 2012.
I mean there was like this fucking Kony
2012 where everybody fucking jumped on
board.
I'm like,
do you even know what the fuck you have
a bumper sticker for?
Do you know that?
I still Hashtag that Kony 2012,
but I'll do it on something that makes
absolutely no sense.
It's just about World Dick joke and I
always put Kony 2012.
I'm like,
I'm not going to let it die,
but it's going to keep.
I don't want it to stay relevant.
Kony 2012.
That's one of my favorite all time human
folly stories.
Because the guy who started that whole
movement meltdown he had.
Oh,
it was amazing.
It was so good.
That was true.
That was true meltdowns.
I think he was probably completely
insane before he started the pressure of
the success of the movement.
Like somehow or another this guy got
celebrities and all these world famous
people were on board because it became
the cause detour,
you know,
it was the thing.
It was the flavor of the month.
I mean he like how long did it last?
So I'm trying to think quite a while.
Six months,
maybe six.
I'm okay.
Something like that.
But it was amazing.
Yeah.
Every celebrity was on board wearing
their tee shirt.
Kony 2012.
So many bumper stickers.
Oh my God.
One day jerking off in front of people
running around the street with your
pants down screen.
Completely naked.
Just on a corner.
And I like,
I Kony 2012.
Don't forget,
don't forget.
Blessed.
And it ended.
It ended like that.
Like that.
That's all it took.
It was like people talked a little bit
about the meltdown and then it was like
something else happened.
We never heard like who knows what that
guy's doing right now,
but to me that embodies the disingenuous
aspect of a lot of the Hollywood like
activism type behavior.
It's like I don't necessarily think
they're really interested in the
activism as much as they're interested
in people thinking they're interested in
the activism.
They're trying to put together a
package,
you know,
and that package is how you look,
how you dress,
how you act,
how you behave,
and you have to have liberal
sensibilities because you want to be
fucking cast so you have to,
you have to connect with these people
that have the casting agents.
You can't have,
you can't be outrageous in,
in any way that's non.
So again,
don't know if you say you're like,
who's that says Rob Schneider.
Somebody said he was a republican.
It was he,
I think he said it,
but it was just lays up fucking vaccine
denier and he's carrying a lot of weird
shit.
But it's like if you.
That's not liberal,
you know,
like kind of I guess the vaccine.
There's a lot of vaccine deniers,
really liberal,
but it's such a weird thing that if you
do something that's not the norm out
here,
everyone just treats you like a bag of
shit and you're like,
yeah,
I don't feel like I don't have that
problem because I'm not an actor.
I'm a writer and I do stand up.
But also I don't know if it's because I
moved out here.
I'm 37 so I didn't move out here at 19
starry eyed with five roommates and
inefficiency,
you know,
like I'm super vulnerable to other
ideas.
I've been working.
I have a stock portfolio.
I bought a house so I didn't really give
a shit the way that I think that if you
come out here so early you're totally
affected by it.
Yeah.
Well I've met a lot of people that were
really young when they came out here and
I met them young when they were out
here.
Like I did a show once back in the day
with this guy who was an actor and he
was like 22 and he was this handsome guy
and he was trying so hard to fucking be
the that God,
you know,
and we were talking about.
Do you remember that Jack Nicholson
movie with um,
Helen Hunt thing is called as good as it
gets?
Yeah.
I fucking hated that movie.
I hated that movie with every fiber of
my being and one of the reasons why I
hated it because I felt sad that this
woman who's a single mom and she seemed
really nice and Jack Nicholson's a piece
of shit and asshole and she's stuck with
them and this is as good as you get.
That was the whole idea of it.
And then this is fucking ridiculous idea
that he was racist because he needed
medication.
So they gave him medication.
He stopped being racist,
like what the fuck kind of movie is I
guess grows.
And so he and I were having this
conversation because it was the movie
that everybody enjoy.
Everyone did she,
it was amazing.
Yeah.
She wanted an Oscar for it and so he and
I were having this conversation.
He was doing that thing that they do
where if it is something that everybody
likes,
he likes it and,
and I go,
I fucking hated that movie.
And he's like,
why?
He goes,
it's amazing movie.
I go,
is amazing.
what the fuck is cheese?
This poor woman was this kid and he says
old cut.
And she stuck with them and he was
getting any better.
So she'd rather sickly kid be around
that.
Yeah.
Creepy dude with sunglasses on.
So he goes,
actually,
I thought he had a lot to offer.
I go,
what?
What did you just say?
He had a lot to offer what but
breathing.
He's my hanging around her money and she
didn't what it that mean?
It's like the whole.
Yeah,
the purpose of that movie was
disgusting,
but when I had this conversation with
him about it,
it became clear really early on when I
started chipping away at it,
like,
what was it that got you about the movie
where it would,
would,
would go well,
but got him.
Is it everybody?
Was saying they liked it,
everybody said they liked it.
So you wanted to say he liked it.
So he was just wracking his brain for.
What was that one thing that person said
about it?
He's an interesting case because he,
he got real,
real hot real quick,
like people were really into them.
But then they found out he was Kinda
dumb and it just drifted away.
It just ended.
So I thought that was okay in Hollywood
you can only be so dumb.
He was real super dumb.
There's a lot of people that they get
like a little bit of juice in the
beginning and like wow,
it's really starting to happen,
should I not?
And then the juice cuts off.
Sure.
And then some new one with maybe better
cheeks or something.
I mean everybody has their moments and
getting hot and then cold and you know,
you hope if you get cold you get hot,
you know?
Yeah.
But
it's really fucking stupid.
I don't know,
like during that whole Chris Brown
thing,
that's my only like examples.
Of course I was getting invited to be on
shows and talk about it and I declined
everything.
It was like,
no,
I'm not good for you.
I was like,
absolutely not.
I wasn't the Chris Brown things.
We talked about it before the podcast,
but if people don't know Chris Brown
obviously was in trouble because of beat
up or Yana and that whole thing and you
know,
the domestic violence issue and you
tweeted something at him.
What did you tweet?
Well,
it was like my lowest form of comedy.
Writing is the celebrity reach weight.
It's because I can't think of anything
else and I'll just go to my favorite
targets like camera Kim Kardashians and
I only make fun of when they write
something stupid.
I never,
I never ever,
like I've never talked about some of
these looks their weight there,
you know,
like it's just something dumb.
And with his,
you know what he did,
he's a horrible person and he had showed
no signs of remorse.
Like he kept doing shit.
He threw a chair through the window and
good morning America and Robert and
Robert's interviews.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean like asking him about it and
apparently they had made some sort of an
agreement where they weren't going to
bring up with domestic violence.
I'm here to talk about my album,
but the whole thing is,
it's like how he channeled his rage,
throwing a chair through a fucking
window really couldn't.
So I was born child and so I was born
and he had tweeted something like,
man,
I look old as fuck and I'm only 23.
And so I retweeted it and I was like,
I know being a worthless piece of shit
can really age.
I thought it was funny and then all of a
sudden like I look at my replies on my
phone and it will look like that
waterfall of just like,
all of a sudden it was like a thousand
$2,000.
I'm like,
Holy Shit,
whoops.
What did I do?
And then I realized he was coming back,
like Gino telling me to suck his dick.
I'm like,
no,
your mother must be so.
But like I just,
I played with them.
It was a Sunday.
I was bored.
And like next thing I know is like he
deleted his entire twitter account and
I'm like wow,
that's not what I meant to say.
One of the shit in your mouth too sharp
in my eye.
Your eye retina to be your specific.
I don't know.
I think he was trying to sound smart
beam accuracy.
Does he have with his is even the back
of the eye.
It's on,
in the front.
Like he didn't even think.
It's just trying to sound smart and I on
your retina.
I was just laughing away and I like he
said like ask Rhiannon if she mad.
I'm like ask Ryanna if she man.
So like I tweeted back and then I linked
his police report to that tweet is a.
I thought it was funny and we went back
and forth for awhile and then he deleted
his account and that's when it became a
thing.
Did he put it back up?
Is this.
It was,
yeah,
it wasn't really like down for like a
couple of weeks or something like that.
You delete your account when you put it
back to you get all your followers back.
Do you have to start from scratch now?
You just start from scratch,
but I.
He has the most insane,
Loyal Group of idiots that follow him.
Just misspelled death threats all day
long is what I got was just misspelled
death threats.
I was like,
well,
you know,
whoops.
But then the next day I was like,
my manager,
like I love the call that I got.
She's like,
Jenny,
what did you do?
A lot of messages here.
And I was like,
yeah,
no,
my bad was like,
just tell them all no.
And she's like,
okay.
And she goes,
are you sure you don't want to?
I've got good ones to view Larry King.
I'll.
I was like,
no view was a good one.
How hilarious.
She was laughing.
She was totally not promoting this and
she's got some good ones I want you to
be on.
We got Larry King,
we got the view and I was like,
no,
no.
I don't want to do it because I didn't
want to.
That's not my intention.
It was just so happened.
That's something that I thought he
wasn't going to take.
They get pissed about,
like,
that ended up being something and it
wasn't how I wanted to make my,
yeah,
self known,
you know,
and I just,
at that point I already had like,
you know,
300,000 followers.
It wasn't like I didn't.
Yeah,
it was just starting out and I was
trying to get fame or something off of
it,
but you doing what you do.
I was doing what I do and it went
somewhere that I didn't ask.
I was like,
ah,
yeah,
no,
I don't want to do that.
And I think about it and like I wonder
if people would.
Somebody said something one time,
did that bother you that that was when
you hot?
I was like,
no,
that is not when I was a hot maybe to
you.
To me that was like,
the low was be like dipping,
you know.
No,
it was not my finest hour.
I was not proud of that moment at all.
I don't regret it,
but I don't.
I'm certainly not going to go sit on the
show and talk about how wonderful I am.
It's like,
no,
I look at what I wrote.
I called it like a fucking ignorant
fucking
that Rosa parks.
Just something near like some heroes,
like no,
he was a piece of shit and I was just,
I like acknowledging that.
Yeah,
that's it.
I wish I knew what happened with them.
I know he beat her and I know you should
never beat.
You shouldn't beat anybody.
You definitely shouldn't beat someone
you love.
You definitely shouldn't be the girl if
you're a guy.
But I want to know what she did.
No,
she might have punched him in the face
too.
And he punched her back or.
Well,
I mean the whole police report is like,
you know,
which he,
he actually acknowledged at all was she
took his phone and there was another
chick texting and she was like,
what the fuck,
you know,
but they're driving and then he punched
her in the mouth and then just kept
punching or driving around.
It was like a 30 minute torture session.
Like what?
Yeah,
like he beat her head until it says and
dot whatever her actual last name is.
Her mouth filled with blood tooth
chipped a.
So he doesn't hit him at all now.
She didn't hit him at all.
She kept trying to get out of the car
and.
But then they break up.
Of course she got a restraining order
and then when that ended she got back
together with him.
Probably give some good Dick.
I guess.
So.
I mean I guess
I don't know if she forgave him.
Shouldn't,
maybe shouldn't have been fucking with
his phone.
Maybe she should have kept her hands
where they belong.
Not on his phone,
but that was such a like,
I mean it was such a,
you know,
when I started getting all I'm like,
oh my God,
my mom is going to like read the shit
that I wrote.
Like I was more just going on.
That was your daughter and that guy was
hitting your daughter
and then just,
Oh,
I'm getting back together with him.
Yeah.
I just,
who knows,
man,
who knows what the fuck.
They're really luck or what she's really
like.
She's obviously a little crazy too.
Yeah.
I mean she'd have to be like a little.
But I think people that are that
talented are just fucking crazy.
Anyway.
Remember her,
who's talented?
Her.
She's very talented.
Her voice.
Yeah.
But a lot of people can say you don't
think she's talented?
Well,
it's just because I think she's,
she saw him for getting back together
with them.
You know,
like,
I have a hard time getting past that.
I don't,
but I don't even listen to new music
anyway.
I'm like,
sit down with an old person driving
around,
listening to lithium.
Serious.
That's.
Do what do you listen?
Like what's,
what's your kind of music?
I'm not kidding you.
That's probably it.
I listened to that eighties,
nineties first wave.
You're like Pandora or Nirvana fan?
Uh,
I like Nirvana already soaked in bleach.
I did.
I didn't really care for it.
What'd you think about it?
I didn't like it.
The movie,
the documentary that thinks that
Courtney
love out.
Pardon?
Kurt?
Purveyance death.
I've seen how many documentaries are
there about him?
There's a few.
There's a lot.
There's a,
there's some real shitty ones.
The HBO One,
right?
Yeah.
Montage of heck.
I didn't see the reenactment crap.
That was terrible.
I was out.
I couldn't finish it actually because
I'm like,
I can't watch bad acting.
Like I thought it was a documentary and
if I'm watching actors pretend to be and
it's somebody else's version of it,
you know,
it,
it felt
like,
no.
Yeah,
I agree with you in that sense.
But I don't think they had rights to
anything else.
I think she owns the rights to Kurt,
you know,
so like I don't think they could do
anything else if they wanted to show
that movie and depict those stories and
how do you just not do it?
Well then they just write a book.
The problem is people won't read books
and another problem is if you want
people to pay attention,
you would have to listen to her actual
voice saying a bunch of crazy shit which
is in that documentary when you hear her
actual voice lying about like having a
drug overdose and making these publicity
stunts and lying to him about where she
found the suicide note or you know,
when she said she found it under the bed
or under the pillows and he's like,
well here's the problem with that.
I checked other pillows.
We chucked under all the pills.
We checked on there everything.
We scoured that room and she said,
yeah.
I says like what?
Like when you hear that and then when
you see the actual physical evidence of
her copying Kurt cobain's handwriting
and then you see the difference between
the suicide note,
which is three mostly like seven,
eight suicide note is him talking about
non related stuff.
And then the last tiny portion of it is
the suicide note,
which is clearly an indifferent
handwriting.
Bigger letters.
And they're like,
Whoa,
did she fucking write this?
Like it still doesn't mean that she
killed them.
It couldn't mean that crazy bitch wrote
a suicide note for him to make herself
look awesome that he loved them.
Just fucking crazy.
She's fucking crazy if I know,
but I don't think there's anybody that
believes that she's not crazy.
Exactly.
I would be.
I don't think there's a person that
would go nuts.
She's totally safe,
so she could be out of her mind.
She could be a liar.
She can be all those things.
It's still not be guilty of murder,
but there's nothing in that documentary
that shows that she killed him.
There's nothing.
It's just that it just shows she's nuts.
Which everybody already knew.
Yeah.
That's when it like it.
Everyone made a big deal about it and I
just like the reenacting really took me
completely picture,
but I've seen so many things.
Like everyone knows she's batshit.
It wouldn't surprise me at all if she
did that,
but.
Well the,
the,
the sheriff killed the police work is so
piss poor.
That was the,
one of the most disturbing things about
it.
When you find out what was it,
like 94 when he died or something like
that was like 1974.
And so we're pre internet.
So the accountability was minimal.
Small town,
you know,
ate a small area and then it was uh,
the Seattle police department.
The sheriff was a fucking idiot,
fucked up a bunch of other cases.
Eventually he was kicked out.
There was all sorts of bad police work
going on on top of that.
The difference between the first
responders accounts of the murder scene
versus his response.
Um,
the difference between the image of the
fucking.
It's allergies,
I'm the first responder said you could
clearly tell who it is and then you
know,
their,
their version of it,
that his face was blown off like,
well those are two different versions of
the fact that they cremated him six days
later.
The fact that they called it a suicide
instantly before the autopsy was
performed,
that you're supposed to leave that to a
forensic scientists to go over the
evidence.
They just as a cluster fuck,
but in that cluster fuck,
but don't try to kill themselves.
I don't believe anything.
I don't know.
I do not know.
The other thing is I don't know.
I don't understand heroin.
So when they say that he had three times
the lethal dose of heroin in his system
and that he wouldn't have been able to
pull the trigger.
I don't know if that's true.
I don't know if maybe he had an insane
tolerance because he did a lot of
heroin.
Yeah,
like maybe three times for you and I,
but not three times for him.
I don't know.
But it was,
it was creepy.
It's creepy documentary.
I mean that whole story.
That whole metal seem as creepy as shit.
I mean,
even like when,
uh,
what's his face?
Scott Weiland it,
read that he passed away.
I mean,
it's so terrible,
but I felt like every single person was
like,
well,
that was going to Scott Weiland.
I met him.
He did.
Dana White's a birthday party dean and
while he was president of the UFC and
performed stone temple pilots performed
at his birthday party and cool for were
swollen.
We just say they were fucking amazing
like three times and every time they
were awesome.
They performed in a,
in a ballroom for.
I mean maybe there was like 200 people
there and the people that were paying
attention when they went on stage,
it was like maybe 40,
like we had to get people up towards the
stage to pay attention.
That motherfucker rocked out.
Like he was in front of $25,000.
Sold out rabid fans.
I mean he,
he hit it hard.
I remember being humbled.
I remember seeing seeing that and going,
wow,
like that guy.
It made me want to do stand up better
and maybe like,
man,
I want to go right.
I want to,
I want to work on my performing because
that guy fucking nailed it.
Gave everything but backstage he was
willing.
He was a disaster because my friends
that had to deal with him,
the friends that worked for the UFC,
that had to like,
like he,
he,
he demanded to go on like right now or
he's getting out of there.
He's going to fucking leave.
I'm on my fucking money.
I want to go on right now like he was
just cracked out of his mind or heroin
out or whatever the fuck he was doing.
He just,
he was like barely you there all the
time and always on edge and you know,
you could blame it on his creative
juices
inside of him that made him such a
genius performer,
which are,
which is undeniable that he was a
genius,
like performance wise and mean.
He put on a show like every time I ever
saw him,
that band play that he was amazing.
But yeah.
Did you read what the mother of his
children said about them?
Like that rolling stone thing him so
fucked up and then you would go to be
married to that and you have children
with that guy and then he had new
children with their new wife and then
just sort of didn't talk to the old.
And of course obviously that's her,
her story.
Who knows how crazy she is,
who knows what the reality of it.
You could die and your ex boyfriend
could write a fucking crazy book about
yearning to be like,
you know,
all fiction.
Yeah,
we don't know,
but this is set.
That's a fucking crazy drug.
That heroin.
Oh,
I would never in a million years touch
that.
What if it made you like so good.
What have you.
What have you got a little bit of heroin
and microdose.
Afraid.
Microdose.
I'd be the one that would die like the
first time trying died first.
I'm trying it.
I'm like,
no,
I gotta let to live for it.
And they find out it's averse reaction
to Claritin,
Claritin,
d.
Oh,
you took the color and the day that 24
hour yet.
Now you're fucked.
You fucked up.
You fucked up girl.
It seems to have an awesome effect on
musicians so well until they die.
Yeah,
but up until up until age 27.
After that,
it seems to drop off radically.
This is like all the age.
Twenty seven people,
right?
Janis Joplin,
Morrison a Hendrix winehouse.
I'm Kurt cobain.
Yeah,
they all.
It's all 27.
So bizarre.
At 27 is the age that everybody just
Illuminati.
It's like that five thing.
It is high five HIV.
That's actually what I have.
That's why it's the age coming out of
your nose.
The night agencies.
We've got to touch it.
AIDS AIDS is acronym.
Yeah.
It's like,
is there a drug that has a more unique
relationship to music than heroin?
I don't think so.
The only comedian that I knew that was a
heroine guy was Hedberg and Mitch
Hedberg had like a sort of almost like a
jazzy sort of sense of humor and it was
like a weird.
Even his voice,
he spoke and everything.
It was like,
it was like a cool cat.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He would do his act sometimes with his
back to the crowd.
It would turn and do it and kill.
He was killing it wouldn't even looking
at everybody.
Well,
there's something about that confidence
due to do something that just fucking
outrageous.
Turn your back to the crowd but not give
a shit.
You're not nervous.
Like they,
they would sniff you out if you were
like,
yeah,
you're scared,
but it's like he had such control over
everybody that he just could do it and
everybody would laugh.
Well,
he was a unique guy in that for a long
time.
He had a real problem,
a following certain acts like when they
would say if you get booked in like the
funny bone and Columbus,
right.
If you get there,
if,
unless you are a big draw to the point
where you say,
Hey,
I'm bringing my opening acts with me.
They would book local people and so they
would have some guy like I know a story
where he went to this club.
They had a local guy,
local guy before him.
His fucking literally doing handstands.
He's singing and dancing.
He has music.
He plays,
he does a wrap to close.
He closed with a wrapped audience,
goes crazy,
and then Hedberg goes up there with
sunglasses on,
stands in front of the microphone and
says,
somebody asked me if I want a banana
frozen banana.
I said,
no,
but I want a regular banana later.
So yes,
that's funny.
But not after some dudes doing flips and
standing on his head and then shooting
rockets on his dick.
You know,
the guy
might be exaggerating,
but you know,
there's like.
So he would bomb.
He would have these horrible sets until
he found his audience and then when
people knew what to expect,
like from lettermen appearances and what
have you,
then they knew what to expect and it
would go to cm and then finally they
started doing the opening act correctly
and that guy had a really hard time
though because of the way we so
specific,
like the kind of comedy,
like you could probably go anywhere and
you could check the crowd out and go
like,
you could figure it,
you know,
in your head when something is working,
what they like and what they don't like,
you know,
even depends if someone's there to see
Gilbert Melendez,
not in the Gilbert Melendez,
he's a fighter.
Medical.
What's his name?
No,
no.
God dammit.
Who the fuck am I thinking of?
Fluffy.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Gilbert.
Gabriel Gilbert.
Like Gabriel Iglesias.
It's super family friendly,
very squeaky clean.
Very funny,
but very fluffy laughing.
If I went on and told some dark shit
after that or some,
it's just not my crowd.
Wrong crowd for me or on a group of old
people that went to see,
you know,
whatever,
fill in the blank with like a really
good carrot tops,
some squeaky clean and that's just,
you can get the wrong crowd for sure.
You know,
there's some crowds that just don't work
for you for your style of humor,
but like if you were going on a show and
it's like you Anthony Jeselnik and bill
burr wouldn't matter.
Right.
It's all the same.
We've done that 20,
30 times at the comedy store.
That's I think probably in my head.
Well the store you'll have,
but that,
you know,
someone might go on and.
Well they're really good at the store,
like setting the lineup and it really
sort of homogenous way.
I did a horrible show there.
I rarely do the some girl I guess was
trying to put together a show and it was
like bring her show.
I don't know what it was.
Yeah,
they'll do like,
I didn't want my room.
Is it a weeknight in the main room?
It was like Monday night in the main
room with a shadows.
Never first time.
Ooh,
I'm in main room,
eight people,
you know,
it was just mad.
It was just absolutely bad.
Everything I said bomb like nothing.
And I was just going
like,
how many more minutes do a red light?
Could you flick that at me?
I mean it was just,
it was bad,
but I didn't like,
this is not my crowd.
Like
they had a show there the other day and
uh,
I got there,
excuse me.
I got there and the waitresses are like,
dude,
go to the main room,
see this fucking show in the main room.
I go,
what's going on?
They go a cult rented out the main room
and I go,
what are you serious?
So I went in there and when I went in
there,
the show was just ending.
The comedy show was just ending.
So some comedian was onstage.
I didn't,
I don't know who the comedian was and it
just wasn't going so well.
I was going okay.
But it was just very,
very strange.
And then after the show they all huddled
up around mother,
mother,
this woman that they called mother who
was the head of the cult and there's
like 50 people around her.
They're all dressed to the nines suits
and ties like the nicest dresses,
like everybody's dressed up,
like they're going to a,
a,
an award show,
right.
And mother sat around with her back to
the stage where they're all facing her.
Like as if she was on stage,
I mean she might as well have been on
stage and she was talking like,
you know,
like really like self help,
nonsense,
sort of fucking cookie cutter
scientology style,
talking about,
you know,
our intention,
what we put out into the world is what
the world gives us back.
If you love yourself,
the world loves that kind of Shit.
And they were all like cheering along
with it and clapping with her and say it
was so fucking strange.
It was so strange.
But they rented the room like how did
they even rent them?
Don't understand what happened.
I don't know what happened because I got
there late,
you know,
I got there like as it was ending,
the last comment was onstage,
but Al Madrigal had been on earlier and
it was just fucking eaten deck up there
and he apparently goes,
what the fuck kind of crowd is this.
Like he was saying it while he was up
there because he realized he looked out
and he sees all these people with suits
and ties and dresses and they're all
there.
They're all fucking super lost.
I mean like really lost strange people.
I'll never forget first sitting there
and then gathered around her,
talking to her,
listening to her every hang on every
word she says.
We saw bird feeding its babies
spit and it was all just waiting for it.
A hallmark card.
Shit.
It was fucking strange.
Really strange.
Yeah.
Well that whole self help thing,
you know if you are,
if you're so inclined you can piece
together,
especially today like it's not.
We're not talking about like Anthony
Robbins days of 1988 or nobody else was
doing it and you had to actually have
some really concise thoughts about how
to improve yourself.
They're repeating other people.
Nobody's come up with something brand
spanking new.
Exactly.
Yeah,
but you.
All you have to do is sort of mind the
internet for these things,
repackage them,
reshape them and put on a seminar and
have all these people together and
there's people that are doing that.
Right?
That voice and that's just that weird,
odd look.
Oh yeah.
I watched that documentary.
The source family.
Do you ever see that one?
No,
I haven't,
but it's pretty Whitney.
Cummings was telling me I have to see
it.
It's good because I don't think anybody
really heard of it because the guy
didn't like do a Mass Jones,
you know,
like he fucking got an angle either in
Hawaii and said,
Jesus wants me to fly out and then say,
yeah,
he didn't make it.
Maybe that's how Jesus wanted them to
come to him.
I was like,
oh,
he didn't kill his people.
He just was like,
nope.
I'm getting vibes that I need to go on
this hang glider on this cliff and
that's a fucked up way to go,
but actually he survived and then died
like a few,
you know,
one or two days later,
something like that.
But Oh,
less,
less exciting.
But it was fun.
Yeah.
I'm sure.
Maybe that's what he was hoping for,
but hang gliding seems like a fucking
great time,
but I'm not trying it.
No.
I need to like,
uh,
no,
I couldn't do that.
Well,
you have to depend on the wind.
I don't like depending on things like
that.
I'm not into depending on wind,
it seems like a,
it does whatever the fuck it wants.
Doesn't want to listen.
It's weird.
Yeah.
It's like tell him no,
that would be like floating in the water
on a boat,
sailing around on a boat in and all of a
sudden the boat decides it doesn't want
to be buoyant and that's kind of what
you're doing.
You're floating in the air depending
upon these drafts with whoops,
fucking reflux.
Claritin,
like a cat.
But if,
I mean,
I think that can happen right?
The wind just dies off and you just
follow him around
much.
I grew up with the coast.
I mean,
Shit.
I wouldn't go fucking hang gliding.
Hell no,
but that guy did because he had his son
told him getting a sign that I need to
hang.
Glide.
Well,
nothing's more nerdy than those wingsuit
dudes.
I had this dude andy stumped in here who
has the world record for wingsuit
travel.
That shit's insane.
I just watched something on it and this
guy,
I mean they're nuts and they'll break
like every fucking boner.
Don't back out there.
I've got to get back out.
Yeah.
One Guy,
he,
he hit his foot on the edge of a rock
and then just going,
you know,
who knows how my fucking fast.
Yeah,
I did see that.
Like everything.
Yeah,
I'm broke.
All of his shitty lived.
Got Right back on it.
That's how awesome wingsuit flying his
break everything.
You have to be there like you have to
have somethings you're wired differently
because that's not.
We have to be wired differently to try
it in the first place.
Right.
I mean,
who would go flying squirrel suit,
you know,
fuck this shit,
this shit to work.
It must be so fun though.
I imagine it is fun.
But boy,
I mean,
have you ever done a hoverboard?
You know,
those little roller board things.
So this little segue,
but it doesn't have a handle.
You know,
those things that they see the kids do.
Well,
yeah,
I have,
they're fun right there.
They are fun.
But those kids,
it's just like two teenagers need to be
on wheels.
Like the little kids have them.
I know.
But you know when you select those lazy
fucking kids in the mall just walking
and then now they're just,
it's so don't you feel that's one of
those things where the technology comes
along before they have rules.
Like remember when people used to be
able to smoke those e-cigarettes on
planes,
they just be puffing on those blue
e-cigarettes like who's that fucking
goofy guy that was doing.
Yes,
yes.
When I saw
him fucking hockey and I was freedom to
seeing you in a movie in 1990.
Like this is what you're doing.
Like what he had to.
But I love it.
He was still like,
yeah,
it's me.
Stephen Dorff.
Take back your guys.
Come on guys.
Take back your freedom.
There it is.
Look,
come on guys.
There's just something so non rebel
about sucking on a little robot Dick.
Yeah.
It looks like they're sucking on a home
pregnancy.
Otherwise those things are great.
Before you go on stage,
they'll look like tobacco or nicotine
rather is a stimulant and it is actually
a good stimulant to take before you go
on stage.
Really fires up your brain.
Joey Diaz told me about it so it gets me
fired up right before and wants to other
vape pens that had like the,
all those big giant fucking like you're
holding onto a lunchbox and the ones
that have like the marijuana oils and
I'm.
Oh I have those right here.
You won't want to travel.
What kinds of you have?
I have all of them.
You name it.
I have.
Do you have the g pen?
I got one of those.
I have a friend that does a friend,
a friend of mine that does marketing ops
endorsed.
We have like a fucking stack of them
back there.
Right.
Those cheap pens.
My friend Bunbee from UGK.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
The best ones are the ones that have the
oil.
Was the one that you screw the top off.
You plug them into USB plot.
I'll call my doctor.
He was my friend who hasn't met.
I got my prescription from a doctor as
well.
No,
I don't have.
I don't even have one,
but he.
My friend has one,
so I was like,
Hey,
if you're up and you're going to go get
me some lessons.
This is broadcast nationally.
You do have one,
right?
You do have a prescription.
You're not taking marijuana illegally.
Right?
I'm totally teasing.
You don't even have one.
You don't even have to have one now.
I don't even have a vape and I was just.
Oh,
you're kidding.
It's just fiction.
It is Joe.
It was one of my friends.
Has it.
Do five guys trying to sound cool.
You one of the cool kids.
Shouldn't be one of the cool kids.
Did you mess with edibles?
She's nodding.
I have in my previous life.
Have you had any bad experiences?
Yeah.
Everybody has.
Everybody's happy because you don't know
how much and it wasn't edibles.
It was the.
I was always the brown.
He said everybody started with and I was
in college and I remember like it was a
costume party.
It was around Halloween so everyone's at
the bar and costume and I couldn't find
my sister and roommate because my sister
and I went to the same college.
I was walking in circles because they
were dressed like
other people and I was like
fucking nightmare scenario.
And then finally they came up to me and
they're like,
you walk past like 30 times and you look
off.
Freaked out.
I was like,
it doesn't help.
I have big eyes too,
so I'm like,
just so fucking panicky and jumpy.
Oh God.
It scared the shit.
I just went back to my apartment and
later I was like,
just make it.
Stop.
Make it stop.
Yeah.
I
was a judge of the Cannabis Cup once.
I don't even know what that is.
The Cannabis Cup is this thing where
they judge a weed and they decide like,
what's the best,
is it like one of those beer?
It's way worse.
Here's the thing,
you don't have any idea which one is
hitting you better or not or you don't
know like this is what the,
you know,
like um,
like old people have like those Monday
through Sunday pillow things and each
one,
you know,
you pop them open and you take it.
It was that.
It would give you one of those.
I said I had it with a dried wheat in it
for like the longest sitting on.
I'm like,
I'm going to save this and I put it
away.
Just does a nostalgia for the highest
I've ever been in my life.
So I get there.
They give everybody that's a judge.
They asked me to be a,
just to give everybody who's a judge,
one of these little boxes with all these
different strains in it and each one has
a name and you know,
Blah Blah Blah.
Now the name,
you're supposed to start smoking it.
Yeah.
So you started some,
but you don't know what,
what's getting you high and what's not
your highest fuck?
First of all,
we went into this place that they did
it.
It was just this place on melrose.
It was like a head shop in the back of
the head shop.
They had this big giant room where all
these people ran and I remember just
being just completely blitzed out of my
mind by the time I got to Tuesday,
Wednesday,
Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday and Sunday I am fucked up man
and people are handing me cookies and
I'm just eating them.
They're just eating them.
People are handing me bags like those a
volcano bags.
I'm fucking sucking on a volcano bag.
I just went as deep as I've ever gone in
my life.
How many days before you came to?
I was legitimately high for 24 hours.
Like I'm not like legitimately.
Did you do anything?
No,
no,
no.
Were you just sitting?
I just laid down after it was over.
I remember thinking I can't even.
I don't even.
I can't even form sentences.
I can't.
Like I didn't know what I was doing.
I didn't know this is,
this is I got,
I got so high that people stopped,
they stopped looking like people to me
and what they started being is like two
dimensional,
like a cardboard cut out like a movie
Promo cutout of a person and then behind
that person was like their soul.
It was like peeking around the corner,
like looking at you like they were
walking towards you with this like
cardboard cutout and behind them this.
That's how the,
that's like the impression that I got
from looking at them.
There's just like a two dimensional
outside and then I could occasionally
seek glimpses of the real self,
like peeking around the corner looking
at me and then Heidi,
I was terrified.
Yeah.
I was just,
I was,
I was untethered,
untethered from reality from life.
I,
I was,
I was gone and I remember having this
weird conversation with this.
Here's the thing about these marijuana
people,
especially marijuana,
this is what we're were talking like I
think I was a judge in 2003,
something like that.
Two thousand two are still in your
system from the problem.
Probably still test positive,
but the people that were into it,
the really involved in the quote unquote
cannabis community.
It was a small sort of tight knit group
that we're producing it and selling it
and growing it and they would gather
together so these,
they would use these things as an excuse
to kind of get together with everybody
and that kind of in this conversation
with this guy who was banking on the
cannabis community,
taking care of him when he was old and
that's what he was like concentrating on
like it was.
I was so high,
just had to listen.
I couldn't even talk.
I was wearing and he was saying,
well,
this amazing thing is the cannabis
community.
Like they're gonna have me,
they're going to take care of me.
The cannabis community will be there for
you.
So right.
Nk with them or something,
you know,
he thought the cannabis community was
like the small,
tight knit thing and now it's a swarm of
humanity.
Even if there is no cannabis community,
homey.
It's called life.
Yeah.
It's just humans.
But to him it was like,
you know,
like local growers or whatever it was
like this local organic community of
work.
So it was just a strange conversation
like that was his angle was almost like
he was like really into pot because it
had given him an identity within this
community.
So he was expressing that to me in this
very strange way and almost trying to
like wrap my head around like what he
thought was gonna happen,
you know.
But he kept saying that,
you know,
the cannabis community,
so always going to take care of me,
the cannabis community.
I'm like,
guess what dude?
The canvas community,
just fucking people like,
people are just going to take care of
it.
Another stoner dude
got out of the room,
one of my roommates in college one time
just ate a shit ton of pot brownies and
she wanted to go to Wendy's for food of
course.
And she's like,
what do you tending to Wendy's some
food?
I was like,
sure.
In my car she's in.
As soon as I go through the drive
through and you're going to,
Wendy's going to take your order.
She goes,
Dr,
just get out of here.
That's when it really hit her part in
that person's saying,
welcome to Wendy's.
He lost her shit.
If I don't drive,
she's going to jump out of my car.
Like she was really like freaked out.
Like just go,
just go.
Just try.
I'm sorry.
Oh No,
it's not good.
But yeah,
pot eating pot can really fuck with you
in a way that nothing else can be any
and it won't go away.
There's nothing you can take or do.
You will have to wait it out.
And one thing that helps a little bit is
coffee.
Coffee does copy cat,
but I mean if you're so whacked out
you're just like,
I just want to sit in a chair and wait
this,
ride this out.
Do you know the different wall?
Here's.
I've talked about this so many times
before.
People gonna get annoyed,
but do you know what happens when you
eat it?
That there's a different like biological
processes opposed to smoking?
When you smoke it,
you're your body's reacting to Thc,
which is the active compound when you
smoke it,
but when you eat it,
it's processed by your liver and it
produces something called 11 hydroxy
metabolite that's five times more
psychoactive than thc.
It's insanely powerful and it's a much
more psychedelic drug.
Like you'll have hallucinations and
especially if you close your eyes,
you can have some really,
really intense.
That freaks me out too much in the
moment.
I close my eyes.
I'm like,
oh,
well.
I was on both when I was at the Cannabis
Cup.
That was what was so fucked up because I
had been high from smoking it.
I don't know anything
horrible.
Throwing it up was great.
If it's alcohol,
if you throw up and you drink alcohol,
you know it gets out of your system and
you,
it helps you sober up quicker.
But like if I was,
you know,
we all do it stupid.
We don't know how we can take when we're
in college and I would drink until I was
like,
just,
you know,
hammered and then I will.
Oh yeah,
I'll look that.
And then I always appeared that'd be the
only time I'd ever puke was when I did
that.
And I'm like,
yeah,
I need to learn.
We'll.
It's also because when you smoke you,
you become hyper aware and you're body
is aware of the poison side to you in
the form of alcohol.
And your body's like,
what did you do?
Get it out.
I took a,
uh,
a pot that sky made thc pills.
It was this,
a friend of mine,
they were like,
he figured out how to make pills and I
don't know how he did it,
but he made them in these capsules.
And um,
you,
you have to,
it has to be.
There's something that has to be fat
soluble.
Like,
like when you cook it,
like a lot of times they cook or they
use butter and they,
they,
they melt the marijuana into the butter
that make it fat soluble.
The make your body.
So,
I don't know the,
understand the process,
but he figured out how to do it and put
it into capsule forms.
So he told us,
he was like,
Yo,
how much should I take?
And he goes,
just take one pill because they're a
little packages of two pills that he
gave us.
It was just take one.
And my friend Eddie Bravo was like,
fuck that guy.
I'm taking it too.
So he took two.
I listened.
I took one and I was fucking the
blitzkrieg and I wound up talking to
this guy and um,
it was at a Jujitsu tournament and this
guy was one of the competitors.
And I remember thinking like,
wow,
this guy's vibe is so crazy.
Like he's giving me like,
when you really hot,
maybe it was just because I'm that high,
like insanely dangerous vibe about him.
Turns out he was a rapist,
turned into a rapist and um,
uh,
was on the run and uh,
went on the run and we went to a Jujitsu
tournament.
No,
no,
no.
He was,
he was a rapist.
He had done some other shit too.
One of the things he had done,
he had choked to death and then they
revived him.
He got in a street fight on a traffic
incident.
One of those mayhem or whatever.
Those.
No,
no,
I'm,
I'm forgetting.
I forget her name.
More machines now.
That was another one.
He was on my podcast and actually just a
couple months before he did that with
the girl that he beat the fuck out if
she was here.
Oh God.
That's the worst sounding story I ever.
I saw the whole thing on real sports.
They did it.
Yeah.
I did.
On real sports on HBO is terrible.
Yeah,
that was terrible.
That whole thing was a combination of
everything is all the abuse that he
suffered in his life.
Steroids,
this fucking brain damage that he
unquestionably has.
So many of them have.
Brain damage is so many fighters.
Same Shit.
The football players.
Yeah.
They snap the chronic and syphilis.
Yep.
Yeah.
Try it.
Well,
cte,
so just any form of head trauma over
repeated periods of time.
Scared cause issues,
but they keep talking about football
players and like you can't tell me that
like Nascar drivers don't have that
shit.
They reckon you have concussions all the
time.
I don't think they were rick that much
though,
but it just takes a little like once
it's,
you know,
once you've had one concussion it's
easier to get another and a lot of those
drivers have had multiple concussions.
That's interesting.
I never really thought about that.
I would think about different people
like hockey.
Sure.
Certainly.
But it always seems to go to just
football.
But you're like,
no,
this.
I mean I know plenty.
I like car racing but like a lot of the
open will,
you know,
even if they have just a barely at rec,
but it's still there.
Had,
you know,
they have all the head neck restraints
on it,
but you hit the side of a wall,
you brand squash around.
You've already had three concussions
maybe in the past.
So with all the connective tissue,
the connective tissue that holds your
brain inside your skull,
that stuff tears.
And when it tears it doesn't come back.
Yeah.
I don't,
I resilient.
It's like it's done.
That's it.
I've,
I didn't know like what that stuff was
like,
like what is the connected tissue leg
until I butchered a moose once and uh,
yeah,
let's go right here.
And when we're lifting up the leg and
cutting the connective tissue,
it's like almost like this,
like candy,
like,
uh,
what's that stuff called?
Cotton candy fibers look and stuff
that's like,
it's so soft.
It just cuts right through.
It's like,
I'm like,
this is similar to the stuff that holds
your brain in your head and you can
imagine over repeated traumatic impacts
like over and over again.
That stuff would just start tearing and
breaking news.
And then once it's torn,
like you're fucked.
Like your head's just rattling around.
Yeah,
yeah.
Scary.
Well,
I have a friend of mine,
a good friend of mine who's an expert in
traumatic brain injuries.
He's a doctor and he treats a lot of
soldiers,
football players,
the like.
And he said that you can get a
concussion,
a severe concussion.
I'm getting hit in the chest like a lot
of football players,
they had impact.
They get hit in the chest,
but the,
that the chest snapped your head back
and your brain rattles around inside
your head and it gives you a massive
concussion and they,
the ignorant
people that didn't know any better,
you know,
ignorant as far as it didn't have the
information they would,
they would say,
oh,
I didn't even get hit in the head.
He's fine,
but no,
that just getting hit in the chest.
Like if someone kicks you in the chest,
you can get a concussion.
I hope nobody ever kicks me in the
chest.
I hope nobody kicks you in the chest to
not be a fan of that suck.
But if they did like you see your brain
gets fucked up.
Have you ever had a concussion?
Oh yeah.
I'm sure you're sure,
but you don't know for a fact that you
had one piece of kickbox.
So did you ever have where you were at
the hospital and they said,
no,
but I definitely had headaches and get
punched in the head a bunch of times.
I've been hit in the head a gang at
times.
I'm just definitely in.
Here's the thing about concussions and
traumatic brain injury,
like people think that it's just a
concussion.
Uh,
you are concussed and defined
concussion,
you know,
oh,
your pupils are dilated and you get hit
in the head.
No,
you like small impacts,
repeated subconcussive impacts.
Sometimes I have the most devastating
effect.
Like soccer players oftentimes develop
the same sort of symptoms from heading
the ball.
Just a ball,
bouncing a ball off your head.
No concussion.
I would have,
um,
I've never had a concussion,
but I assume that I've done damage from
surfing or wakeboarding.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Like,
you know,
you would know it.
Take you a minute.
Like you really wipe out and you're just
like laying there,
like
take a deep breath.
Like,
okay,
I'm going to sit the next few.
Dr Mark Gordon
was saying that you can get it from
wakeboarding or I'm not.
Sorry,
I'm jet skiing.
Just hitting weights
jarring.
Exactly.
It really like when you hit,
if you're,
you know,
every time I'd be out on the boat or
somebody that you go into a wave and
that kind of like,
boom,
yeah,
it's good enough.
Fuck,
you get off the boat and you're just
like kind of.
We could fill a little rattled.
Yeah,
exactly.
that Shit's bad for you.
Not Good.
I would imagine ski jumping,
ship boom.
Like that.
All those fucking downhill skiers like
the ones that the Olympics and the fuck,
they wiped the fuck out.
Oh,
they fucking wipe out those a
snowboarder.
Dudes do.
Oh,
they wipe out hard.
My friend who got knocked out recently
fucking snowboarding.
He.
You ever seen that document up on his
back?
Oh really has no idea what the fuck you
did?
Just woke up.
It was fucked up for awhile.
But this is like a second or third time
going out like that too.
Like falling snowboard.
He loves snowboarding though.
But Jesus
point again,
like I like walking and breathing and
living on my own.
Remembering where I live.
Not having somebody like,
you know,
take me to the bathroom.
Like,
well for football players you've seen
those.
If you've seen the real sports episode.
I am
NFL players from the seventies and
eighties that are just jobs.
Well,
the one I saw,
it was a pbs frontline that was about
those concussions and,
and it was,
I mean,
the guy's just,
they're not the same person,
they're just fucked.
I mean they've just done a number on
their bodies and you don't bounce back
after so many just hoping that one day
they're going to figure out how to
inject stem cells in your brain or
something like that to reinvigorate it.
But yeah,
as of right now,
they really can't do much.
Are you a football fan?
Not really,
no,
but like growing up.
Okay.
So you know,
you think about you'd see a big hit,
it would make this know wide world of
sports real or some shit like that.
And you're like,
do you want to watch it again?
It's just insane.
And everyone's like,
yeah,
and they're fucking and now I see it.
And I'm like,
yeah,
that guy that just shaved about 10 years
old,
you know,
like,
and he's probably lost however many lost
whatever function of his brain that they
say is like your emotions and your
decision making.
And that's why a lot of those guys will
shoot their girlfriend killed themselves
and we're going to show one jamie.
Oh,
oh.
And then you can always tell my guys
this recent.
Jamie.
Yeah.
This was two weeks ago.
You can tell the knockout when the hand
stamp.
Oh yeah.
No,
believe me.
I know,
I've seen.
I've probably seen more people get
knocked unconscious in real life then I
would,
I would,
I would really,
without any reservation say that I've
seen more people get knocked out then
zero,
zero point one,
one,
one percent of the population.
I'm like in the,
like the smallest group of people,
like there's maybe a hundred or 200
people on the planet that have seen more
people get knocked out than me.
Maybe
I've seen people get knocked out not to
that extent,
but because of my sports producer I used
to have to actually go to all the games.
So I'd be on the sideline,
you know,
like.
So I saw it,
you know,
like right there up close.
And it is,
I mean you just see it coming.
You could see the guy coming.
You can see his head turned the other
way,
has no idea what's you know,
and then the moment he just lays down
those arms just oh yeah,
they just stay up until like
fuck.
Well because of doing commentary for the
UFC,
I mean literally I've seen more
knockouts than way more than 99 percent
of the population.
It's probably like 99 point nine,
nine,
nine.
There might be,
there might be 20 people on earth that
have seen more people get knocked out
than me.
It might really be that low because how
long have you been doing that?
I've done.
I started doing the commentary from 97
and I started again.
I did it from 97 and 98.
Then I quit and then came back in 2002
with the new company and I've been doing
it for the last 14 years.
But you've seen a lot of.
But I also was fighting from the time I
was 15,
so was 15 to 22 was all kick boxing and
martial arts.
So I saw a lot of people get knocked out
in person there and then I saw was just
fucking done.
God called like,
I don't know man.
It's way more than a thousand fights.
It's probably close to 2000.
So I've probably seen five or 600 people
just get shut off.
Just wham.
Over the course of my life.
Just Bong,
crying,
stiff arms,
legs twitching,
toes curled.
I've seen that way more than 100 times,
200,
300 times.
Yeah.
It's madness.
When you really stop,
think about it.
I mean it's weird that like going from
something I would watch and be like,
oh,
you know,
watch it again to like,
now I'm just going,
Jeez,
you know,
me too.
We're getting old.
It's not fun anymore.
Well,
it's
becoming more and more aware.
And plus like the knew will smith movie
concussions coming out where people are
starting to say no I haven't.
Is it out already?
Yeah.
Came on over Christmas,
but I didn't do.
I don't think what it should have.
Yeah.
I read something that there was like
this long thing of discrepancies,
like they chose to leave out because
supposed to be a true story,
you know,
and,
and they,
they admitted very important facts.
Oh look,
because of the nfl of how they treated,
you know,
like there are certain things that I
don't know who got behind what and like
who kind of strong arm,
strong arm them into like doing what
leave that part out,
but that part in or maybe try to avoid
lawsuits to something like that.
But I mean I used to think when I would
hear people like,
I mean I grew up in Texas too,
so football was such a big thing.
And how there would be people that would
say,
oh,
I'd never,
I'm not letting my son play football and
your pussy and I get it now.
Like I don't have kids,
but I would say I get it.
Like you see the results in these
people.
It just fogged.
I get it.
Yeah.
Well I mean if boy,
if my kids wanted to fight,
I would be very conservative about it.
I'd have to.
I'd have to really try to get it into
their head to understand defense before
anything really.
You have to like the most important
thing to practice is learning how to
avoid being hit and how to.
Yeah.
I mean I took like,
I took karate as a kid,
everything,
but you know,
my dad was like,
you never start a fight.
He's like,
but if somebody ever tried to hurt you,
he's like,
Jimmy,
I just punched him right in the nose and
keep doing it until like,
but defend yourself,
don't,
you know,
don't dance around them and talk shit,
you know.
And I was like,
okay,
well avoiding fights is always to get in
a fight.
Don't hit me.
I'd be so upset.
Why don't you do that?
Well just if you didn't avoid it and you
got hurt,
badly hurt.
Yeah.
And something you could have avoided it
feel so stupid.
It would have been forever.
Yeah.
That you're the one that started it and
then you get the shit kicked out of you.
Cooler heads.
Prevail is always a good thing to focus
on.
It's just sad.
It's almost always whatever the fuck it
is that people fight over,
it's almost always going to be worked
out.
Most of the time.
People just want to fight when they're
drunk and that's the difference between
alcohol and pot.
Nobody fought at the Cannabis Cup,
those fucking people,
and even had a fight that day.
I want to just grab it.
Let's just slowly answer for say,
Hey,
slow dance me and you man talk.
Come on man.
I don't know what to tell you about,
but let's talk.
Fuck the people come out of a bar to
fire it up.
It is the worst drug when it comes to
that.
The worst,
the worst job because it narrows your
understanding of the danger that you're
involved in.
Loosens inhibition impedes rational
thinking and it's always somebody that's
so fucking hammered,
but they can't even put one foot in
front of the other,
but in their mind they're seeing
something completely different and they
always end up getting the shit knocked
out of them.
I've seen it,
seen it a bunch of times.
It's horrible.
It's seen.
Street fights is always so strange too
because sometimes you see street fights
with people that are so confident and
they literally have no idea how to fight
and you're like,
why are you so?
What are you doing?
You don't even.
Maybe they beat up somebody that was
really scrawny.
They're like,
it's going to happen to get that good
God.
Look at that big giant bouncer.
I got this and you're.
I always want to like if you ever met
someone that like they become a
different person when they get drunk,
they drink and then like a switch goes
off.
If they're not,
they're like,
hey,
when Jenny go with Jenny,
Jenny in there,
and those eyes are just like,
they get gerbils,
hamsters and then you say something,
then it's usually the people that get
mad really easily.
We were just having fun like,
well fuck this shit,
fuck this fuck of.
And was looking at me.
Yeah,
because your drink's empty.
Like
what the hell happened to you?
Where'd you go?
Kind of amazing that.
So few fights do take place.
When you think about how much alcohol is
available and how many people drink,
it's kind of amazing when you go out and
you don't see a fight,
which is more often than not.
Right?
Depends on where you're at.
I think when I was in Austin,
so you've got on sixth street and it's a
good place.
It was.
It would be weird to not see a fight on
sixth street,
but then if you go to a place that's
like a nicer,
you know,
okay,
these are adults instead of a bunch of
just college kids that are ripped.
You don't see as many,
but that's true.
I saw a lot in Austin.
That was pretty,
pretty common.
Well,
college towns and then you got Texas
people and then he got booze and you
throw it all together.
A lot of fucking Johan.
It's a great town though.
I love great town.
A town.
It's getting choked up with people
though these days.
Everybody wants to live there now.
Why is that?
Don't know.
It's cool as shit to do.
It's a nice place.
That was fun.
Like I said,
it's a good atmosphere.
It's not.
I think it's laid back that help
traffic.
There's insane.
No,
yeah,
that's started becoming like just.
Yeah,
it's overwhelming.
Their infrastructure can't really handle
it because it's not designed for that
many people and,
and everything's consistently under
construction that never get,
you know,
it's just like everything.
There's just,
you know,
they're all going gonna be a new
building that's going to be it.
Okay.
So we have to close that street off and
that straight offs.
Traffic's now worse.
It's a problem.
But it is a very unique city in Texas
too because it's got its own vibe to it
as opposed to.
Yeah,
I mean this is the capital,
but it's got its own vibe to it that's
different than any other Texas city.
It's so liberal and open minded and
sweared.
I mean I think that like I worked
downtown and where the office,
where our station was was right there
next to the capital,
so it was kinda cool.
It was on Congress and you could walk
around.
It was,
you know,
I didn't live very far.
I mean I was still young so I had a
little cool dope ass little high rise,
you know,
it was fun,
but I,
I feel like every time I go back it's
just thousands more people.
Oh yeah.
We'll do some nutty number of people
move there every day.
It was like a thousand people moved
there everyday or something like that.
Something insane.
Something really ridiculous.
And it is sprawling because you can go
out towards the lakes and all those kind
of houses.
How many people move to Austin every
day?
Google that.
I bet there's a statistic,
but yeah,
by the lake will the lakes.
They used to be two lakes,
right?
Lake Austin,
Lake Travis and Lake Travis had fucking
become nothing but there was town lake
and then yeah,
like travis is now,
like just speed boats.
Everybody filled up again.
It was down to nothing and it rained so
hard.
It filled back up again.
That was pretty fucked up because nobody
could even get in the water due to the
bacteria.
It's only 110.
One hundred and 50.
That's it.
That's nothing.
Oh,
when for 2014.
So two years ago,
how much much difference to that doesn't
seem like a lot though because 150
people move in and 40 people move out.
So it's 110 net.
That doesn't seem that bad.
But it is over the course of years.
Right?
Yeah.
Well so much for my fucking outrageous
hyperbole,
hyperbole.
Kinda almost.
It is almost.
Almost close.
Yeah.
Close enough.
It's sucks.
Three hundred 60,000 people a year.
No,
week 50 2:52 weeks.
One of my shitty math again.
Boy.
Fucking relying on calculators.
Oh Man.
I have to rely on calculators.
So we're almost out of time.
Jenny Johnson.
High Five.
Where people.
Where can people see you do stand up
next?
When are you next?
Uh,
where am I performing next?
I believe that I have anything this
week.
Maybe next week.
Okay.
I'd probably put it up on your twitter
and let people know what I'm on my,
a gram on my instagram.
Cool.
I'll let people know.
Please do.
I will.
All right.
Jenny Johnson high five me on.
Oh,
by the way,
my cousin Andy next.
He's Moraine,
major,
fly [inaudible],
big fan of yours,
so thank you andy.
I told him I would tell you that.
All right,
well thanks.
This was fun.
Appreciate it.
Let's do it again.
We can be sponsored by Claritin D.
we'll do it again when it's not raining.
Perfect.
All right.
Thank you so much.
Thank you Johnson.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Yeah.